WE GOT A CALL TO ORDER THE SAID
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF
THE SENATE.
HEALTH IN THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEES AND ON AND
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTING AND
FUNDING FOR THE CONTROL REGULATE
AND TAX ADULT USE OF MARIJUANA
ACCESS --
YOUTH EDUCATION PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
ACCOUNT AND WHILE WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE AND I'M LIKE.
THE ONE I THINK --
MY CHAIR I CO CHAIR FOR THE SE
HEARING I COUNTY LEAVE A AND IT.
TEACHING COMMITTEE AS WELL BEING
HERE AS YOU KNOW --
PROP SIXTY FOUR IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN CREATE THE YOUTH
EDUCATION PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
ACCOUNT WHICH MAKE FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO VERY STATE
DEPARTMENTS. FOR PROGRAMS FOR
USE WITH OR AT RISK OF
DEVELOPING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
IT'S BEEN SEVERAL YEARS NOW --
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR AND NO FUNDS HAVE BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE FOR THE USER ACCOUNT.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO HEAR.
NGUYEN FUND ABOUT EXAMPLES OF
SERVICES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR USE AS WELL AS
SERVICE GAPS THAT MAY BE
ADDRESSED BY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND THE WORK HAS BEEN DONE TO
DATE TO PREPARE FOR FOR WHEN THE
FUNDS ARE MADE AVAILABLE.
THE GOAL IS TO GAIN A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW WELL THE
VARIOUS ENTITIES HAVE BEEN
COLLABORATING AND TO IDENTIFY
AREAS THAT MAY NEED IMPROVEMENT.
AND SO WITH THAT --
ONE NOW INVITE.
CENTERS LEYVA CHAIR OF THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ALSO US A FEW WORDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE FOR THE
HEARING TODAY.
I'M VERY PLEASED THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE FOCUSING OUR ATTENTION
ON THE USE OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR FUNDS THAT WILL BE
DEDICATED TO PROGRAMS FOR WHICH
YOUTH. FOR YOUTH WHICH WILL
EMPHASIZE EDUCATION PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION AND SCHOOL
RETENTION THIS TOPIC IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE ERA OF LEGALIZATION OF
MARIJUANA AND THE OPIOID CRISIS.
AS A MEMBER OF BOTH EDUCATION
AND HEALTH COMMITTEES I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED.
IN HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WILL COMMUNICATE
AND COORDINATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP A YOUTH FACING
INTERAGENCY.
AGREEMENT THAT BUILDS UPON
EXISTING LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURES
AND PROGRAMS.
AND OTHER ANY OTHER MEMBERS THAT
WANT TO MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS.
ALL RIGHT DOCTOR PANEL TOBACCO
VIDEO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA
SO WE'RE GONNA FIRST BEGIN WITH
AN OVERVIEW OF THE YOUTH
EDUCATION PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
ACCOUNT AND I LIKE TO INVITE OUT.
CLINT CALLUM ASSISTANT PROGRAM
BUDGET MANAGER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
AND SONYA PROTECT.
THE FRANTIC CORRECTLY --
FROM THAT SENIOR FISCAL POLICY
ANALYST AT THE LET WITH THIS
ACCOUNTS ABOUT.
A WELCOME THANK.
HI COMPOUND APARTMENT A FINANCE
AND MY TESTIMONY TODAY WILL JUST
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
EXISTING CANNABIS RELATED --
FUNDING STRUCTURE TO KIND OF BE
ABLE TO SEE HOW. TO USE.
EDUCATION PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
ACCOUNT FITS INTO THAT.
SO THERE'S TWO MAIN FUNDING
SOURCES THERE'S A CANNABIS
CONTROL FINE WHICH RECEIVES
REVENUETHROUGH REGULATORY FEES
ON THE LICENSED MARKET --
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE EXPECT
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE SPENT FROM
THAT FIND IN IT MAINLY FUNDS THE
THREE MAIN LICENSING ENTITIES.
CANNABIS CONTROL DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE --
FOR TODAY'S DISCUSSION THE NEXT
ONE'S MORE RELEVANT --
IS THE CAMPUS TAX FUND.
IT GENERATES REVENUE ON A 15%
EXCISE TAX ON RETAIL SALES
CANNABIS ANNA CULTIVATION TAX
WHICH IS BASED ON A PER OUNCE
WEIGHT OF THE PLANT ARE CERTAIN
COMPONENTS OF THE PLAN.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ARE
CANNABIS EXCISE TAX REVENUE --
IS IT SHOWS THAT WERE EXPECTED
TO GENERATE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND GIVEN THAT TO NEWLY
CREATED MARKET THESE REVENUE
PROJECTIONS OR IS SUBJECT TO
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY.
PROP SIXTY FOUR ACTUALLY LAID
OUT HOW.
CANNABIS TAX FUNDS WERE INTENDED
TO BE SPENT IN GENERAL TERMS
THERE'S THREE MAIN ALLOCATIONS
AND THEY'RE IN PRIORITY ORDER --
ALLOCATION ONE IS GOING TO
REGULATORY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS.
INITIALLY WERE YOU REPAYING
GENERAL FUND LOANS THAT WERE
USED WHILE NO --
THE REVENUE --
TO IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY MARKET
WHILE REVENUE WAS UNAVAILABLE.
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES WE EXPECT IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE AND REGULAR COURT
REGULATORY COSTS.
THEN THERE'S ALLOCATION TO WHERE
THEY SPECIFIED SPECIFIC DOLLAR
AMOUNTS TO GO TO CERTAIN
RESEARCH AND OTHER PROGRAMS WE
EXPECT THAT TOTAL TO BE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
A GRANT PROGRAM TO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES TO STUDY THERE --
A FACT OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR IN THE
OVERALL EFFECTIVE LEGALIZING --
CANNABIS THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR SEATS P. RELATED TO IMPAIRED
DRIVING IDENTIFICATION TRAINING
AND BEST PRACTICES TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO GO BAY IS FOR A
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT PROGRAM
IN TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO UC SAN
DIEGO CENTER FOR MEDICINAL
CANNABIS RESEARCH.
AND THEN FINALLY --
WE GET TO ALLOCATION THREE WHICH
IS OF INTEREST TODAY.
AND BASICALLY THE WAY THE
INITIATIVE WORKS IS THAT IT
LOOKS AT REVENUE IN A GIVEN YEAR
AND THEN IT COVERS THE
EXPENDITURES AND ALLOCATION ONE
INTO AND THEN WHATEVER'S
REMAINING.
IT MAKES AVAILABLE FOR
ALLOCATIONS THREE IN THE
PRECEDING FISCAL YEAR SO WE
EXPECT IN NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO BE AVAILABLE IN TOTAL
FOR ALLOCATION THREE PROGRAMS --
BUT AGAIN AS I POINTED OUT THAT
THAT'S BASED ON OUR OUR REVENUES
TODAY WHICH IS SUBJECT TO
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY.
AND 20% OF THAT REVENUE GOES TO
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION
PROTECTION ACCOUNT.
WHICH IS TO BE USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION FOR REMEDIATION
EFFORTS.
RELATED TO ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE
FROM CANNABIS THERE PROGRAMS
THIS INCLUDE COULD INCLUDE
PREVENTION AND ENFORCEMENT
RELATED TO ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROW
SOME PUBLIC LANDS. 20% TO THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNT WHICH WOULD
GO TO C. H. P. ACTIVITIES
SIMILAR TO THOSE A SCRIBE ABOUT
AND MAYBE A GRANT PROGRAM LATEST
THAT.
IT ALSO GO TO THE BOARD OF STATE
COMMITTEE CORRECTIONS FOR AND
SEND TO SEND MONEY TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVEN'T BAND --
CANNABIS RETAIL SELLER
CULTIVATION FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES AND FINALLY --
FOR TODAY'S DISCUSSION 60% OF
THAT --
ALLOCATION THREE WOULD GO TO THE
YOUTH EDUCATION PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
ACCOUNT --
WHICH WOULD --
GO TO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO WORK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AN APARTMENT EDUCATION ON
SUBSTANCE USE RELATED --
TREATMENT PREVENTION AND
EDUCATION --
THAT'S THE CONCLUSION OF MY
COMMENTS AND HAPPY ON ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M SEND YOU
PICK FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND I'M ALSO
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE MARK
NEWTON WHO IS THE DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AT THE LA --
MY COMMENTS TODAY WILL OFFER
SOME OVER ARCHING THOUGHTS ON
THE ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
IMPLEMENTING --
THE USE ACCOUNT.
AND TO THAT END ALL FIRST
DISCUSS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE UNRESOLVED IN THE LANGUAGE
OF GOVERNING THE USE ACCOUNT AND
THEN I'LL MOVE ON AND DISCUSS
FIVE KEY.
ISSUES WE RAISE FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A HANDOUT
ASSOCIATED WITH MY COMMENTS OKAY
GREAT.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE ONE WE
PROVIDE A LIST OF THE UNRESOLVED
ISSUES IN THE YOUTH ACCOUNT
LANGUAGE THESE INCLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE --
THE LANGUAGE IS SILENT ON A
SPENDING PRIORITIES FROM AMONG A
LOT A LONG LIST OF PERMISSIVE
ACTIVITIES IT'S ALSO SILENT ON
HOW THE THREE DEPARTMENTS SHOULD
WORK TOGETHER. ONE IMPORTANT
AREA THAT IT'S SILENT ON IS THE
ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T
MENTION THE LEGISLATURE AT ALL.
AND IMPORTANTLY IT CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATES THE FUNDS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
DESPITE THIS WE ASSUME THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN USE ITS GENERAL
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY WHEN IT
COMES TO IMPLEMENTING THE USE
ACCOUNT FUNDS.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF SOME OF
THESE UNRESOLVED ISSUES.
AND WE THINK THAT IN DOING THIS --
WHAT IT CAN REALLY DO IS HELP
GUIDE THE DECISION MAKING BY THE
THREE DEPARTMENTS AND PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK FOR DECISION MAKING?
AND WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN BE GUIDED BY
SOME OF THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT.
AND YOU'LL KNOW IN THE HAND OUT
THERE'S A NUMBER OF SOMETHING
THAT WAS BASED ON A LESSON.
LESSON LEARNED FROM PROPOSITION.
SIXTY THREE SO IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE THREE WILL RAISE OUR ISSUES
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST IS THIS NOTION OF
IDENTIFYING OUTCOMES TO ACHIEVE
THE LANGUAGE IN PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR IS SILENT ON WHAT OUT
SPECIFIC OUTCOMES IT HOPES TO
ACHIEVE WITH THE SPENDING OF THE
YOUTH ACCOUNTED DEFINITELY
IDENTIFIES SOME.
A PERMISSIVE ACTIVITIES BUT NOT
THE ACTUAL OUTCOMES.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE STATE IN STATUTE THE
THREE TO FIVE YOU KNOW SMALL
HANDFUL OF OUTCOMES THAT IT
HOPES TO ACHIEVE WITH THE
SPENDING.
AND IDENTIFY MEASURABLE TARGETS
ASSOCIATED WITH EACH OF THESE
OUTCOMES WE THINK THAT THIS CAN
REALLY SET UP A FRAMEWORK FOR
DECISION MAKING BY THE
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE THEY'LL FLOW
FROM THESE GOALS.
SECOND WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE STATE ITS INTENT ON
OVERALL PREFERENCES AS WELL AS
PREFERENCES FOR HOW IT WANTS TO
CONDUCT OVERSIGHT AND WHAT
REPORTING IT WANTS TO REQUIRE OF
THE THREE DEPARTMENTS --
FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD STATE ITS INTENT TO THAT
THE INITIAL FUNDING BE USED FOR
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES ONLY
AND THAT EASE PILOT PROGRAMS TO
TEST --
PROMISING PRACTICES AND INCLUDE
A FORMAL EVALUATION REQUIREMENT.
TURNING TO PAGE FOR OUR THIRD
ISSUE THAT WE WANTED TO RAISE IS
HELLO THE LEGISLATURE COULD
FACILITATE ITS OVERSIGHT WITH
THE CREATION OF A TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
WHAT WE SUGGEST HERE IS THAT IT
COULD CREATE A SMALL GROUP OF?
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE EXPERTISE
IN TECHNICAL ANALYSIS AND AND
DATA --
USING DATA.
AND WE THINK THAT THIS COMMITTEE
CAN HELP LATER IN THE
DEPARTMENTS WHEN IT COMES TO
IMPORTANT DECISIONS SUCH AS HOW
TO SET UP EVALUATIONS FROM THE
OUTSET WHAT DO YOU DO NEED TO
COLLECT IN ORDER TO DO THOSE
EVALUATIONS.
IT COULD ALSO HELP ASSESS --
SERVICE NEEDS AND SERVICE GAPS.
I'M TURNING TO PAGE FIVE OUR
FOURTH --
ISSUE WE WANTED TO RAISE IS.
HOW TO RESOLVE SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT WERE LEFT UNRESOLVED
IN THE LANGUAGE --
THERE'S SOME DECISIONS THAT MAY
NEED TO BE.
CONSIDERED AT THE OUTSET SO FOR
EXAMPLE AND THIS IS A LESSON
LEARNED FROM PROPOSITION.
SIXTY THREE HOW DO YOU WANT TO
HANDLE UNSPENT FUNDS BY FOR
EXAMPLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHOULD
THEY BE ALLOWED TO KEEP A
RESERVE WHEN SHOULD THE FUNDS
RESERVE REVERT BACK TO THE STATE --
THERE ALSO DECISIONS THAT SHOULD
BE MADE ON AN ONGOING BASIS SO
FOR EXAMPLE.
AND THIS IS ANOTHER LESSON
LEARNED FROM PROPOSITION SIXTY
THREE WE THINK THAT DETERMINING
THE RELATIVE IMPORTANCE OF
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES VERSUS
TREATMENT ACTIVITIES IS GOING TO
BE AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND RATHER THAN LOCKING IN THOSE
PROPORTIONAL ALLOCATIONS WE
THINK THAT THIS SHOULD BE A
FLEXIBLE DECISION IT SHOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD.
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENTS TO
RECONSIDER ON AND MAYBE AN ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND PERHAPS
ANNUALLY WITH GUIDANCE FROM THE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AM BASED ON LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE PREVIOUS ACTIVITIES.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT THING THAT
WILL NEED TO BE CONSIDERED ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS IS WHETHER THE
FUNDING SHOULD BE --
ALLOCATED VIA COMPETITIVE GRANTS
OR FUNDING FORMULAS AND ON THIS
WE THINK THERE MAY BE ROOM FOR
BOTH SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
EVIDENCE ON A PARTICULAR.
ISSUE IS SPARSE IT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE IF TRANSPORTATION OUT --
PROMISING PRACTICES AND THEN
CONDUCTED EVALUATION WHEN THERE
IS A LOT OF EVIDENCE IN A GIVEN
AREA YOU COULD POTENTIALLY USE A
FUNDING FORMULA AND PROVIDE SORT
OF A MENU OF OPTIONS OF EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER ENTITIES
COULD USE.
FINALLY OUR LAST POINT THAT WE
WANTED TO RAISE IS THAT THERE
WILL BE WORK FORCE NEEDS
ASSOCIATED WITH --
IMPLEMENTING THE USE ACCOUNT
FUNDS WE THINK THAT --
ASSESSING IN PLANNING FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IS AN
ACTIVITY THAT SHOULD HAPPEN AT
THE STATE LEVEL BECAUSE
STATEWIDE NEEDS COULD BE --
BETTER ASSESS THAT WAY WE ALSO
THINK THAT THE DEPARTMENTS IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON ANY STATUTE THAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT SAY
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAMMER OR LOAN
FORGIVENESS THAT TYPE OF THING.
SO WTHOUT I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES CENTER STONE.
ALL THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND YOU CERTAINLY
OUTLINED SOME OF THE EMISSIONS
IF YOU WILL.
OF INITIATIVES SO.
THE FIRST THING THAT I THINK WE
WE CERTAINLY NEED --
TO IDENTIFYING TACKLE IS --
THE DEFINITION OF YOUTH.
AND I'M ONLY SPEAKING FROM SOME
OF OUR EXPERIENCES ON THE
COMMITTEE WE ARE WE CAN LOOK A
CHRONOLOGICAL AGE OR WE CAN LOOK
AT BRAIN MATURATION AND BRING
NATURAIS XIN SEEMS TO BE --
A PREDOMINANT FACTOR --
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THE
BRAIN DOESN'T FULLY DEVELOP
UNTIL TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
AND SO -- I
WOULD COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD CONSIDER
DEFINITION OF TWENTY FIVE YEARS --
FOR YOUNGER --
IDENTIFYING OUTCOMES I THINK IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT --
EDUCATING OUR YOUTH ABOUT THE
THE INTOXICATION HAZARDS OF OF
CANNABIS ESPECIALLY WHEN.
GETTING BEHIND THE WHEEL OF A
CAR FORCING A LOT.
MORE KIDS AND ADULTS FOR THAT
MATTER --
BEING ARRESTED FOR D. WHY IS
DRIVING UNDER THE THE DOCKS
CATION OF OF CANNABIS.
AND AND CERTAINLY --
EDUCATING OUR KIDS ABOUT THE
SYNERGY.
OF OTHER DRUGS INCLUDING ALCOHOL
WHEN MIXED WITH --
WITH CANNABIS.
AND AND ALSO THE HAZARDS OF
CONSUMING EDIBLES NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE CONCENTRATION
OF CANNABIS THAT IS IN THOSE
ARTICLES BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
I DON'T THERE'S ONE REPORTED
CASE OF ANYBODY --
DYING FROM AN OVERDOSE OF
INHALED CANNABIS BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN INSTANCES ESPECIALLY AND
AND CHILDREN OF PEOPLE EATING
APPLES AND SING ON UNFORTUNATE
DEATH SO.
MR SURE HOW THIS WILL WORK TO
ARE WE ARE WE LOOKING FOR A BILL
TO CLARIFY LANGUAGE OR HOW HOW
DOES THE LEGISLATURE --
PLACE THEIR INPUT BASED ON A
CONSENSUS OF THE COMMITTEES
[inaudible]
OF CAN I CAN I WEBER TORTURED
ASKING EVERYONE BECAUSE I'M
LOOKING FOR AN ANSWER BUT WILL.
EXPLAIN.
AS I CAN LOOK AT THE ROLE THE
ROLE OF US AS IT HAD A COMMITTEE
TO TRYING --
TO FILLING THESE GAPS OF
INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THINGS ARE DEFINED OUR GOALS ARE --
OUR FOR OUR FULLY OUTLINED WHAT
ARE THE STEPS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENACT THESE --
THESE VOIGTS IN THE AN
INITIATIVE.
IT'S WE WE DID CONSIDER THE
ISSUE IN DEPTH IN ONE AND
BELIEVE THAT THE HANDLING THIS
PROCESS THROUGH POLICY BILLS
PROBABLY MAKES THE MOST SENSE.
AND NOW IT'S A PART OF THE
REASON WE'RE DOING THIS --
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS TO
START TO GET THE OUTLINES WILL
BE HEARING FROM --
ADVOCATES AND AGENCIES AS WELL
AND THEY MAY HAVE SOME IDEAS TO
BUT VERY SECURITY SEE THIS IS A
A BILL OF THE COMMITTEE ALL COME
VERY IDEAS AND TESTIMONY THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD UNDERTAKE AS
MOBILE THE EIGHTH --
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS AFTER YOU
HAVE A THE SAID AFTER AFTER THIS
HEARING SEE WHAT DIRECTION SO.
THAT'S IN THE COMPARATIVE BUT
PEOPLE SUGGESTIONS ALWAYS OPEN
TO THOSE CELL THANK YOU I MEAN
AND OF YES I'M SORRY I WAS JUST
GOING.
TO MAKE ONE MORE COMMENT ABOUT
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO DO TO IS
WHEN YOU HAVE VERY SPECIFIC
IDEAS ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
POLICIES YOU WANNAPUT FORTH AND
CUT CONSULTING WITH LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL AT THAT POINT TO
DETERMINE WILL WHAT'S ALLOWED
WHAT CAN WE DO.
WHAT A THREE DO WE HAVE MIGHT
MAKE SENSE?
THANK YOU SO MUCH CAN I MAKE
WHAT SIR CAN I MAKE ONE MORE
COMMENT TO ABOUT --
THE ISSUE YOU RAISED ON THE
DEFINITION OF USE.
WE AGREE THAT THAT DEFINITION
SHOULD PROBABLY BE KEPT BROAD
BECAUSE THIS SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER CONF AFFECT A WIDE
RANGE.
OF AGES AND WE IN FACT RECOMMEND
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE STATING ITS
INTENT THAT.
THAT YOUTH BE KEPT THE
DEFINITION BE KEPT VERY FINDING
THAT IT'S TWENTY FIVE OR UNDER
BUT IF YOU'VE ESTABLISHED THAT
FRAMEWORK OF OUTCOMES THAT YOU
HOPE TO ACHIEVE.
THEN THE THE SPENDING DECISIONS
THAT ARE MADE SHOULD TARGET
THOSE GOALS SO WHATEVER THE AGE
MIGHT BE I MEAN PERHAPS SOMEONE
COMES IN JUST OVER TWENTY FIVE
AND YEAH.
THANK YOU CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU TO THE CO CHAIRS FOR
CONVENING THIS SESSIONFOR THE
OVERVIEW --
EVIL PROVIDED.
I THINK SPRY FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUT FOR ANYONE --%
YOU MENTION KIND OF THE THREE
CATEGORIES FOR THE TAX REVENUES
ARE DISTRIBUTED.
WITH THE CATEGORY THREE BEING A
REMAINDER OF WHAT'S LEFT OVER
AFTER YOU FILL CATEGORIES ONE
INTO.
AND THEN YOU PROJECTED BUT SAID
WITHOUT PRECISION TO HONORED SIX
MILLION PROJECTED.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY HAVE WE
COLLECTED REVENUES ALREADY IN
THIS CATEGORY THREE SINCE THE
LEGALIZATION IN THE SALE.
OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS SO --
WE'VE COLLECTED THREE QUARTERS
SO FIRE SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
TO THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
THAT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS --
IS THAT TOTAL OR SENT FOR THIS
CATEGORY THAT'S TOTAL I DON'T
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THE
SPECIFICS AND WHETHER WE'VE
REACHED A LEVEL WHERE WE'VE PAID
ONE INTO TO REACHED CATEGORY --
THREE BUT YOU KNOW --
EX I BELIEVE WE'RE CLOSE TO
GETTING TO A POINT WHERE THE
NEXT TAX --
PAYMENTS MADE WILL ACTUALLY
START FUNNELING INTO ALLOCATION.
THREE FOR NINETEEN TWENTY BUT
WE'RE STILL COLLECTING IN THIS
BUDGET YEAR AND WE CAN HIT THAT
TRIGGER IN THIS BUDGET YEAR
[inaudible]
POTENTIALLY.
RIGHT SO THE FINAL TAX PAYMENT
ACTUALLY FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WILL BE THE END OF JULY SO IT'S
EVEN SORT OF FURTHER IN EVERY
YEARS IN THAT YOU IT WILL BE A
PAYMENT MADE AFTER THE END OF
THIS FISCAL YEAR THAT APPLIES.
TO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
WHATEVER'S AVAILABLE AT THAT
POINT --
WOULD GO TO THESE ALLOCATION
THREE PROGRAMS INTO THE THREE
CATS --
PERCENTAGES THAT ARE BROKEN DOWN.
THANK YOU IN IN JUST A BRIEF
COMMENT FROM.
I DO THINK THIS WORKIS CRITICAL
IN THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
EXERCISE KEEN OVERSIGHT IN
SHAPING --
YOUTH EDUCATION IN I THINK THE
LA --
SUGGESTED NOT TYING OURSELVES
INTO ALLOCATIONS BETWEEN
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT.
THEY'RE BOTH OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE.
THE BETTER JOB WITH HIM
PREVENTION THE LESS WE HAVE TO
DO IN TREATMENT.
AND JUST TO GET ON THE HORIZON
AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
LOOKING AT THE NEXUS BETWEEN THE
VAPING PRODUCTS THAT KIDS ARE
USING IN SCHOOLS NOW.
FOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND THOSE
DEVICES ARE ALSO USED --
FOR MARIJUANA CANNABIS IN
ELATION IN I KNOW FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH POINT OF VIEW WITH MADE
SUCH TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN
REDUCING.
FIRST TIME TOBACCO USERS WITH.
IN THIS VIRTUALLY ALL BEEN
ERASED AND REVERSED NOW WITH
VAPING.
LIVING NICOTINE TO SCHOOL KIDS
ONLINE SIX HUGE PROBLEM IN OUR
PUB IN ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS --
BUT JUST TO POINT OUT THERE IS A
NEXUS OF KIDS BEING INTRODUCED
TO THE VAPING PRODUCTS THAT'S
ALSO --
MAKES THE CANNABIS PRODUCTS
ACCESSIBLE SO IS PART OF OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION --
HOW CAN WE PARTNER WITH THOSE
THAT ARE TRYING TO DO?
TOBACCO REDUCTION EDUCATION --
JUST JUST AS A THOUGHT SO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I THINK YOU JUST MOVED TO WITH
REGARD TO REVENUE ASSET
CHRISTINE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SO WE WE EXPECT --
TO FIND OUT SAID WHAT REVENUES
WERE COLLECTED FOR THE SECOND
QUARTER OF THIS FISCAL YEAR AT
SOMETIME WITHIN THE COMING DAYS --
IF THE ERROR OF THAT BUT SO FAR
ARE AT THIS MOMENT ALL THAT
WE'RE AWARE OF IS --
REVENUE THAT WAS COLLECTED FROM
THE FIRST QUARTER OF THE FISCAL
YEAR AS WELL AS STANDARD THE
PRIVATE LAST HALF OF THE PRIOR
FISCAL YEAR END.
AND COUNTING ONLY THAT REVENUE
TO DATE --
YOU JUST FROM THAT FIRST QUARTER
THE FISCAL YEAR IT STILL REMAINS
SORT OF ON CERTAIN CERTAINLY NOT
GUARANTEED WHETHER THERE WOULD
BE.
REVENUE AVAILABLE FOR THE YOUTH
ACCOUNT --
IS THERE THERE WOULD BE AS AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTED
BY THING THAT'LL DEPEND
CRUCIALLY ON SHOULD THE NEXT
COUPLE OF OF REVENUE UPDATES --
WHETHER THERE WILL BE REVENUE
AVAILABLE FOR THE ACCOUNT AND IF
SO HOW MUCH.
I THINK TO HELP ILLUSTRATE THIS
A LITTLE BIT BETTER --
TO IF YOU LOOK.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND LOANS
THAT NEED TO BE REPAID WE HAVE
ABOUT FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
ALLOCATIONS FROM ALLOCATION ONE
INTO THAT NEED TO BE PAID.
NINETEEN NINETEEN WE'VE RCEIVED
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO DATE WHICH DOESN'T
INCLUDE THIS TAX PAYMENT THAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO RECEIVE.
SO IT SEEMS LIKELY THAT THIS
NEXT TAX PAYMENT WILL LIKELY
COVER THE ALLOCATION ONE INTO
COSTS AND WILL START TO BEGIN TO
SEE.
RAINY REALLOCATION AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN JUST REACT TO THAT
QUICKLY --
THIS CONSTRUCTION IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE THIS CATEGORY.
THREE REQUIRES FILLING THE FIRST
TWO BUCKETS FIRST AND SO IN
TERMS OF PREDICTING WHAT YOU
HAVE. TO DO ADVANCE PLANNING ON
PREVENTION OR TREATMENT PROGRAMS --
IT'S REALLY KIND OF AN IMPERFECT
STRUCTURE.
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW FOR BEING
ABLE TO DO.
SOUND INVESTMENT PLANNING WHEN
YOU'RE WAITING EACH YEAR TO SEEN.
QUITE WHAT MIGHT SPILL OVER INTO
THAT CATEGORY THREE I KNOW THIS
ISN'T YOUR CREATION.
YOU ARE BOUND TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO IMPLEMENT IT WITH US
BUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD IDEAS.
MAYBE AT SOME OF THE RESEARCH
THAT GOES ON WITH SOME OF THIS
MONEY BUT HOW DO WE GET BETTER
PROJECTING.
ANTICIPATED TAX REVENUES SO THAT
THERE COULD POTENTIALLY BE
COMMITMENTS ARE ADVANCE LOANS
MADE FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO TO
MAKE SURE WE WE ARE FULLY.
PROMOTING THE EDUCATION
PREVENTION AND REATMENT
PROGRAMS AND NOT.
HOLDING IMPLEMENTATION IN
ABEYANCE BECAUSE WE'RE NOT SURE
WHAT WE'RE GONNA GET SO I KNOW
IF THERE'S A PRESIDENT FOR THAT
KIND OF LOAN AND ON SOME AMOUNT
KNOWING THAT.
YOU'LL GET SOMETHING THERE BUT
YOU'RE NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT IT
IS -- THAT
WOULD ALLOW.
FOR PLANNERS AND IMPLEMENTERS TO
MOVE FORWARD SO.
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT THAT.
YEAH I POINTS WELL TAKEN --
ANYTHING COURSE STILL SORT OF
WORKING THROUGH THOSE DETAILS I
DO THINK THAT AT LEAST THREE
QUARTERS OF THE PRIOR YEAR'S TAX
PAYMENTS WILLBE IN BEFORE THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR.
SO WE'LL HAVE ONE TAX PAYMENT
THAT TAKES PLACE AFTER --
AND I THINK AS THE MARKET
MATURES I'M ASSUMING THE BE MORE
STABILITY IN THOSE PROJECTIONS --
BUT IT UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT'S A
CHALLENGE THAT THE DEPARTMENTS
WILL HAVE --
TO UNDERTAKE.
YES ASSN RUBIO THANK YOU.
FORGIVE ME FIGHT AND SEE IT AND
SOME OF THE PAPERWORK THAT YOU
PROVIDE IT BUT I'M JUST A LITTLE
CURIOUS I KNOW IT'S AND YOU
INDUSTRY AND THERE'S A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS.
I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW WE ARE
GOING TO RECRUIT MORE PEOPLE TO
GO INTO THESE PROFESSIONS IN
TERMS OF THE THE MENTAL HEALTH --
WELLNESS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
I'M JUST ONE SIR CAN WE USE
FUNDING FOR LIKE LOAN
FORGIVENESS.
PROGRAMS TO GOING TO THESE
FIELDS I CAN ONLY IMAGINE.
THE PROBLEM I GONNA GET BIGGER
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE THE USE
OF CANNABIS AT A MORE AND MORE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND AND I
HAVE TO TELL YOU PERSON I COME
FROM A LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHERE WE
WE DID GET ABOUT FIFTEEN PERMITS
AND WE ARE STARTING TO SEE --
SOME OF THE UNANTICIPATED
CONSEQUENCES OF THOSE PERMITS
AND SO.
WE'RE TRYING TO SEE A LOT MORE
USE OF CANNABIS OUT IN THE OPEN
AND KIDS FALLING PREY. TO TO THE
USE OF CANNABIS A PERHAPS IS NOT
TO A QUALITY I DON'T KNOW VERY
MUCH ABOUT CANNABIS BED.
SO MY POINT IS I THINK WE'RE
GONNA NEED A LOT MORE
PROFESSIONALS IN THIS INDUSTRY
HOW TO WEEK.
PROMOTED HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE
THEM AND DOT CAN WE USE SOME OF
THAT FUNDING FOR LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS FOR THEM TO
GO INTO THE FIELD.
AND BECOME EXPERTS IN THIS ARENA.
YES WE AGREE THAT THERE IS --
SOME UNMET NEEDS IN THIS AREA WE
DON'T HAVE NUMBERS ON HOW MANY
NEW PROFESSIONALS WE WOULD NEED
TO IMPLEMENT THESE PROGRAMS BUT
THE TYPES OF PROFESSIONALS THAT
WILL BE NEEDED CAN RANGE FROM.
YOU KNOW PRIVATE TRAINING FOR
PRIMARY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
SCHOOL COUNSELORS TO NURSES TO
EVEN SUPPORT SPECIALIST.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE THE
LEGISLATURE --
WORK WITH THE THREE DEPARTMENTS
TO DEVELOP SERVICE STATEWIDE
STRATEGY TO INCREASE --
TRAINING AND WORK FORCE IN THIS
AREA.
AND THAT COULD CERTAINLY INCLUDE --
LOAN FORGIVENESS OR SOME.
AND THAT MIGHT BE WERE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN REALLY HELP THE
THREE DEPARTMENTS IN IN ACTING
STATUTETHAT FACILITATES THAT
[inaudible]
THANK.
QUESTIONS OKAY SIDE AND IF
COUPLE QUESTIONS IN A FOLLOW UP
AND SO DID TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE YOU MAY NOTE THAT --
YOU KNOW THERE'S ACTUALLY A LOT
OF DIFFERENT.
THAT DESERVE PERMISSION WE COULD
USE SOME HELP WITH WHAT WOULD
YOU SEE THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE RESIDING YOU TALK
ABOUT.
ITS RESULTING LEGISLATORS
OVERSIZE AT THE PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE PART ADMINISTRATION
WERE WORRIES.
BUT FENNELL AS PERSPECTIVE --
WHERE WOULD YOU SEE THE --
THE BETTER THE AT THIS TECHNICAL
VISOR COMMITTEE BEST BEING
SITUATED.
YEAH I KNOW THAT SIR THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION AND I
THINK THAT --
FOR SOME OF THOSE TYPES OF
DETAILS IF IT'S AN ISSUE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
PURSUE WE WOULD BE HAPPY.
TO WORK WITH YOU TO EXPLORE THE
THE VARIOUS OPTIONS BUT WE
REALLY SAW THIS AS A COMMITTEE
THAT COULD.
REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO HELP --
DEPARTMENTS WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO.
HAVEN'T QUITE WORKED OUT HOW
THOSE DETAILS AND WOULDN'T DO
YOU EVER OF TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEES ARE PART OF THE LA L..
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A HIS YOU
ARE OUR ADVISORS AND MANY OF
THESE ALL WILL.
BUT ONE MASSIVE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE YES.
THINK ABOUT IT IS I I JUST FEEL
WORK -- AND
THEN THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
FOR FINANCES IS THAT --
SO I APPRECIATE THAT WE DON'T
ALWAYS KNOW IT SO THAT'S OF
BASICALLY YOU AND SILENCE A WELL
WE HAVE X. NUMBER DOLLARS.
IN THIS ACCOUNT WE DO THIS
ANNUALLY ANY.
AND AND SAY THAT NOW WE HAVE
THIS MUCH MONEY FOR PART THREE
FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR WHEN WE
FIND OUT DID MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION WE HAVE.
EX NUMBER OF DOLLARS FOR FOR
THIS FUND.
THAT IS SO THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I DON'T THINK A KNOW
WITH PRECISION THE ANSWER TO
THAT GIVEN THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED MONEY TO THIS THIRD
ALLOCATION YET BUT WE DO.
SO --
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR REQUIRES
THAT WE SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
CONTROLLER BY JUNE FIFTEENTH.
IN IN THERE WE SORT OF DELINEATE --
ALLOCATION ONE WHAT DEPARTMENTS
GET WHAT AMOUNT OF MONEY BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT SPECIFIED THEN WE
PROVIDE THE ALLOCATION TO
CONSISTENT WITH THE INITIATIVE.
AND THEN I ENVISION THAT WE
WOULD JUST SAY ALLOCATION THREE
WOULD SAY WHATEVER'S REMAINING
GOES IN THIS PERCENTAGE FORM TO
THESE DEPARTMENTS.
AND IT WOULDN'T BE UNTIL WE GOT
THAT FINAL TAX PAYMENT AT THE
END OF THE JOE I THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY KNOW IN TOTAL WHAT THEY
HAVE IN A GIVEN YEAR TO SPEND
OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY THINKING
ABOUT OUR BUDGETING PROCESS WE
DO OUR GENERAL FUND BUDGET YOU.
KNOW HOPEFULLY SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S FISCAL YEAR STARTS
JULY FIRST BUT IN TERMS OF THIS
FUND.
THERE'S A LETTER ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH FOR THE PRIOR FISCAL
YEAR RIGHT. FOR THE NEXT FOR THE
COMING FISCAL YEAR THE COMING
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY BUT IT'S
BASED ON THE IDEA OF WHAT WAS
SPENT IN EIGHTY NINE OKAY AND
WHAT WAS RECEIVED AN H. OKAY.
SO THE IDEA OF GOD SORRY BUT IN
TERMS OF DETERMINING HOW MUCH
MONEY WILL FINALLY LAND IN THE
SPOT.
THAT THE PROP THREE I GUESS --
DIRECTLY --
YOU WE WOULD KNOW THE FINAL
TAXIS IS AND OF JULY SO WE WOULD
NOT ACTUALLY KNOW FOR THIS FINE
HOW MUCH MONEY EITHER IS MOVING
FORWARD UNTIL.
TARGET SOMETHING --
RIGHT YES AND AND SO THIS ISN'T
A BUDGET ACT SO THEY WOULD GO IN
THERE CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE
SO THAT AND LETTER IN THE FACT.
IS SORT OF OUR BUDGET MECHANISM
TO PROVIDE THE DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S SO IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T LINE UP PERFECTLY I
GUESS WITH OUR BUDGET ACT
PROCESS OF IN THEY WOULDN'T KNOW
UNTIL ABOUT AUGUST OKAY.
BECAUSE PART OF WHAT I'M ALSO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT TIMELINE
WISE --
MAYBE QUESTION FOR BOTH OF YOU
IS -- HOW
THE LEGISLATURE EXERCISES
OVERSIGHT OVER?
THE SPENDING OF THE SON OF THESE
FUNDS RIGHT BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY THERE IS SO
NOW THE MONEY SHOWS UP WE NOW
HAVE A SOME SOME.
IN AUGUST.
AND DANDER NEEDS TO BE A PROCESS
TO I GUESS.
SPEND IT AND HOW DOES IT ACT
LEGISLATURE EXERCISE OVERSIGHT
ABOUT HOW IT'S SPENT.
SO I THINK WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH AN FIGURE OUT THOSE
DETAILS I'M AT THE NAY REVISION
ON THE ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO
SHARE THEIR ALLOCATION THREE
PLAN AT THAT TIME.
THAT'S NOT DISSIMILAR HOW WE DID
IT LAST YEAR TO JUST ALLOCATION
THREE PROGRAMS WERE AVAILABLE
FOR EXPENDITURE IN --
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH ON
SORT OF HOW THAT INDEED WILL
HAPPEN I THINK IT'S HAPPENED IN
THE NORMAL SUBCOMMITTEE ROCESS.
BUT IN EFFECT YES WHAT IT
WHATEVER GOES INTO THAT LETTER
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH SORT OF
SOLIDIFIES WHAT THE PLAN IS
MOVING FORWARD.
AND AT THAT TIME I THINK WE'VE
HAD A GOOD IN YOUR MAYBE THE
PRECISE DOLLAR AMOUNTS.
AND I THINK A CERTAIN THE LA --
OPINIONS ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT GIVEN THE
NATURE OF THE TIMING OF THE
FUNDS AN YEAH THE CENTER PAN
MARTIN LA OKAY.
I THINK A KEY THE KEY POINT TO
RECOGNIZE IS THE THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS AUTHORITY OF
THESE FUNDS SO.
SO WELL THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T
HAVE ITS TYPICAL BUDGET --
APPROPRIATIONS AUTHORITY THAT
OVER SO I CAN BE EXERCISED IN
MANY DIFFERENT CONTACTS SO
REALLY THIS PROPS WHILE THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE COULD BE
INVOLVED --
THIS IS --
PROPS MORE IN IN LINE WITH THE
THE POLICY COMMITTEE FUNCTION
AND OVERSEEN THROUGH THAT AND
AND AND AGAIN OVERSIGHT CAN COME.
FIRST AND FOREMOST FROM SETTINGS
SORT OF IN STATUTES SORT OF
PARAMETERS FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
FOR PREFERENCES AND DIRECTION
AND THEN HAVING ONGOING SERVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS IN TERMS OF HOW WELL
THE DEMONSTRATION IS LIVING UP
TO THOSE SET THOSE GOALS ACTED
WITH THE THE BUDGET.
TIMELINE AND THEN ONE OTHER
QUESTION FOR FINANCE SAID SAYS --
WE'RE ANTICIPATING WE DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE THAT WE MAY ACTUALLY
HAVE FUNDS --
FOR THIS COMING YEAR --
IS -- BEEN --
ADDED OF THE RING COMMUNICATIONS --
AND I WENT TO A DIRECTION
BECAUSE YOU DON'T BUT
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE RELEVANT
AGENCIES TO START PLANNING --
FOR THOSE FUNDS --
BECAUSE IT FOR THE MONEY SHOWS
UP IT ON BE SITTING ON THEY'RE
GOING WELL GEE YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO WITH IT SO
AND WHAT.
HAVE YOU HAS AS IT BEEN SOME
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
APPROPRIATE IN SEASON THEY
SHOULD START PLANNING.
FOR WHAT THE MECHANISMS --
FOR THAT THEY WOULD WE HAVE IT
JUST HAD.
INITIAL DISCUSSIONS I MEAN THAT
THE MOST THESE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
BEEN AWARE FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO RECEIVE
SOME FUNDS AT SOME POINT HAVE
FROM THE CANNABIS TAX FUN.
I'M S I DON'T THINK THEY'LL BE
SURPRISED BY THAT BUT SO WE HAVE
BEGAN SOME INITIAL DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AFFECTED DEPARTMENTS
AND WE'RE JUST SORT OF ROLLING
THAT INTO OUR SPRING BUDGET
DELIBERATION PROCESS.
ENVISIONING THAT WE WOULD HAVE A
MAJOR REVISION PROPOSAL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER OKAY
SAID WE ARE GOING TO BE HEARING
FROM THE AGENCIES --
LATER ON SO I I ANTICIPATE BASED
ON WHAT YOU JUST SAID THAT THEY
SHOULD RAISE THE PLANNING THIS
OF RABIES SHARING WITH US THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING TO
FIGURE OUT THIS OUT.
AND I THINK THEIR THERE REALLY
IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS BUT AS I
STATED I THINK THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL WILL ACTUALLY SOLIDIFY
THOSE DETAILS AND WE OULD WANT
TO GET OUT IN FRONT OF THE
GOVERNOR ON ANY OF THOSE DETAILS.
OKAY BUT IT HAD A COUPLE YEARS
PREPARE.
I I MEAN I THINK MOST OF THEM
ARE AWARE THAT IT'S BEEN OUT
THERE BUT I DIDN'T GET MADE IT
LEAD THE AMOUNT HAS BEEN UPSET
RIGHT NOW HIGHLY --
MOVING ALL AROUND --
A IT AND SO I I YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR
PEOPLE TO RECONCILE --
IN SO YEAH IN IN JUST
UNDERSTANDING THE MECHANICS OF
IT ALL HAS BEEN COMPLICATED EVEN
NOT FOR US TO WORK THROUGH AND
TRYING.
TO GET FOLKS ENGAGED BUT PEOPLE
THAT A COUPLE YEARS TO FIGURE
THIS OUT.
RIGHT WE GO I'M SORRY MR THE
CALLER SAID PEOPLE HAVE HAD A
COUPLE YEARS TO FIGURE THIS OUT
RIGHT.
THAT IT THE IT'S THE INITIATIVE
HAS BEEN PASSED SINCE NOVEMBER
[inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN LATER.
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTION --
YES S. UNDER ALSO ON CAN YOU
SUMMARIZE FOR ME THE SOME.
SOME OF THESE KEY NUMBERS AND
GOT A MALL CONFUSED.
SO [inaudible]
WE'VE COLLECTED.
WHAT AMOUNT OF MONEY?
BUT WE HAVEN'T SPENT IT.
AND A BECAUSE I HEARD YOU SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT LOANS IN THIS A
SO WHAT'S THE AMOUNT COLLECTED
AND HOW MUCH HAS BEEN.
SPENT.
YES I'M I'M I'M HONESTLY I'M
MOVING THINGS BETWEEN FISCAL
YEARS TO TRY TO PROVIDE A SIMPLE
ILLUSTRATION BUT IN.
IDEALLY WERE GOING TO SPEND A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ON
ALLOCATION ONE INTO IN SUCH A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION OF THAT
IS FOR GENERAL FUND LOANS THAT
TOOK PLACE IN PRIOR YEARS.
WITH CALLS LOANS. TO GET THE
REGULATORY A PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE TO
STAND UP TO LEGALIZE I CREATE A
LEGAL MARKET HOW MUCH IS AT A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION OF THE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT OKAY
SO HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION TO GET.
THE PROGRAM GOING THOSE TOOK
PLACE IN PRIOR YEARS YEAH AND
WE'RE REPAYING THAT AS THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF REGULATORY
COSTS THAT ARE ALLOWABLE UNDER
ALLOCATION.
ONE OKAY --
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ALLOCATION WANT.
ONE COST OF TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETY AND THEN IN
ADDITION WE HAD TO THAT WE HAVE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ALLOCATION TO COST IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WHICH GETS US TO THE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION.
AND IN TOTAL EXPECTED
EXPENDITURES FROM ALLOCATION ONE
IN TWO TO DATE AGAIN I'M
CROSSING FISCAL YEARS BUT TO
JUST SORT OF ILLUSTRATE THIS
WE'VE COLLECTED OF ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN CANNABIS TAX FUNDS.
SO OUR NEXT PAYMENT.
THEORETICALLY I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT IS WOULD PAVE FINISH PAYING
OFF THAT HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION AND THEN THERE WOULD BE
SOME PORTION THAT IN THEORY
WOULD BE.
APPLICABLE TO ALLOCATION THREE
AVAILABLE IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND WHAT --
WHAT WAS PROJECTED TO BE THE
AMOUNT IKNOW LOTS OF ISSUES
IMPACT THAT BUT WHAT WAS
PROJECTED --
I DON'T KNOW.
ORDERLY BREAK DOWN ON THE AMOUNT --
WIN TOTAL WHERE ARE WE CLOSE ARE
WE WAY BELOW ARE.
BUT SO BASED ON THOSE THREE
QUARTERS OF TAX PAYMENTS IS HOW
WE ARRIVED AT THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PROJECTING AN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
I'M WERE YOU CAN.
NOW I'M NOT OKAY GUYS WHEN HE
WAS.
ON IF.
QUESTION FOR YES AND RUBIO AGAIN
THIS IS ALL NEW TO ME THE WHOLE
CANNABIS AND AND TWENTY WITH THE
EDUCATION PART OF IT I KNOW THAT
THE GOAL IS TO EDUCATE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE KNOW.
WHAT WE'RE DOING I'M JUST
CURIOUS IS THERE --
SOMEONE THAT ACTUALLY GOESOUT
TO THE COMMUNITY TO HAVE
IMPLEMENTED GIVEN PERMITS TO
REALLY GET REAL TIME DATA AS TO
HOW IS IMPACTING THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
SO THAT WE CAN PREPARE IN TERMS
OF THE EDUCATION THAT GOES INTO
IT BECAUSE EVERYTHING IN.
THE AREAS GRAY BUT IN PRACTICE
DOESN'T ALWAYS TRANSLATE ARE WE
GOING OUT TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THATARE CURRENTLY.
NOW IN AND YOU DON'T HAVE
PERMITS AND ARE DOING BUSINESS
SO ACTUALLY I CENTER RUBIO.
POLISH ICE --
I'D SO IT'S SOUND LIKE WE LACK
WHICH EDUCATION PREVENTION EARLY
INVENTION.
AND TREATMENT ACCOUNT SO --
SO I JUST WANNA BE SURE THAT WE
CAN START ASKING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WHOLE ENTIRE
THING -- AND
IN FACT I I URGE --
FINANCE TO HAVE A DIRECT
COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT THAT AND
THAT SURE TO YOUR OFFICE AND YOU
GET THE INFORMATION YOU WANT
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
BY ALSO JUST WANNA BE CAREFUL IN
TERMS OF THIS HEARING WHICH I
FOCUS ON THIS PARTICULAR ACCOUNT
CELL AND IT IS.
NOT THANK YOU SORRY WE CHAT OKAY
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION --
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA BRING
UP BY THE NEXT PANELS --
STAKEHOLDERS EXPERIENCES
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OVERSIGHT OF THE
FUNDED PROGRAMS SO --
WE HAVE JULIET SENS SOCIAL
PROGRAM DIRECTOR TO PREVENTION
INSTITUTE DR JIM COOLER
ADMINISTRATOR.
CALIFORNIA FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE
PARTNERSHIP TULARE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND WARN DANIEL
SISSY STRATEGY OFFICER COMMUNITY
COVERAGE AND RESOURCES.
AND SO --
APPRECIATE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL BEING HERE AND FOR SHARING.
SOME OF YOUR PERSPECTIVES AND
EXPERIENCES THAT MIGHT HELP
INFORM OUR STATE AGENCIES WHEN
WE FINALLY DO HAVE MONEY COMING
IN ABOUT WHAT --
SOME THINGS WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
DO -- CHIEF
WITH THAT THIS --
FUNDS THAT THE VOTERS HAVE VOTED
TO TO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR LEYVA JAPAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS JULIE AT SAM'S AND I
REPRESENT PREVENTION INSTITUTE.
A NATIONAL NON PROFIT WITH
OFFICES IN OAKLAND AND LOS
ANGELES.
WE COLLABORATE WITH COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO ADVANCE COMMUNITY
BASED EQUITY FOCUSED INITIATIVES
THAT PROMOTE HEALTH SAFETY AND
WELL BEING.
MY REMARKS TODAY ARE ABOUT WHY
IT'S CRITICAL TO FUND PREVENTION
VIA THE YOUTH ACCOUNT WITH THE
SPECIFIC GOALS OF ADVANCING
HEALTH AND RACIAL EQUITY.
THERE'S AN OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
THAT WHERE WE LIVE ARE
SURROUNDING ENVIRONMENTS ARE THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT SHAPERS OF
HEALTH AND WELL BEING BECAUSE
THEY DETERMINE OUR OPPORTUNITIES.
WHAT WE ARE EXPOSED TO AND WHAT
WE CONSIDER NORMAL OR EXPECTED
PATTERNS OF BEHAVIOR?
INVESTING IN PREVENTION AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL IS HOW WE CAN
SHIFT THOSE FORCES IN THE
ENVIRONMENT TO MAKE HEALTHY AND
SAFE BEHAVIOR IS THE NORM.
WILL ALSO PROMOTING HEALING AND
RESILIENCE AMONG YOUTH WHO HAVE
BEEN EXPERIENCING TRAUMA AND MAY
BE AT RISK OF SUBSTANCE USE.
PREVENTION SPECIFICALLY PRIMARY
PREVENTION IS DEFINED AS
COMMUNITY LEVEL EFFORTS THAT
PROMOTE HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS AND
BEHAVIOR TO PREVENT INJURY BILL.
ILLNESS AND INJURY FROM
OCCURRING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND WHEN WE APPLY THIS TO
SUBSTANCE USE FUNDING PREVENTION
MEANS PREVENTING EXPOSURE TO AND
USE OF SUBSTANCES AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE SAME
STRATEGIES THAT PREVENT INITIAL
USE.
ARE ALSO CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN TREATMENT AND
RECOVERY IN SHORT EVERYONE
BENEFITS WHEN ENVIRONMENT
SUPPORT HEALTH AND SAFETY.
WHEN FUNDING PREVENTION THERE'S
SOME CORE ELEMENTS OF A
SUCCESSFUL INITIATIVES AND
PROGRAMS TO KEEP IN MIND?
FIRST WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
COMMUNITY LEVEL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH SO THOSE ARE FACTORS IN
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT STRONGLY
INFLUENCE HEALTH BEHAVIORS AND
OUTCOMES.
AND THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES OF
YOU FLED AFTER COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTS.
A DESIRE FOR SAFE ACCESS TO
PARKS AND OPEN SPACE FOR EXAMPLE
HAS LED SOME COMMUNITIES TO
FOCUS ON REVITALIZATION OF PARKS.
INCLUDING YOUTH DEVELOPED
PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE ACCESSED AT
PARKS AFTER SCHOOL AND AFTER
DARK.
PROMOTING SOCIAL CONNECTIONS AND
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY.
OTHER COMMUNITIES YOU'D HAVE
ORGANIZED TO AFFECT CHANGE
AROUND WHAT IS SOLD AND PROMOTED
WEIGHING IN ON ZONING
REGULATIONS AND OTHER POLICIES
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTHY
FOOD.
AND LIMIT THE REACH OF TOBACCO
AND ALCOHOL MARKETING ALONG WITH
OTHER PREDATORY BUSINESSES.
THESE APPROACHES CAN FOSTER A
SENSE OF PURPOSE AND BELONGING
FOR YOUTH IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THE SECOND ELEMENT IS THAT WE
MUST ELEVATE YOUTH LEADERSHIP
SET WITHIN THE YOUTH FIND WE CAN
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE GATHERING
AND ENGAGING WITH ONE ANOTHER
SERVING AS LEADERS AND DEFINING
THE AGENDA FOR THEIR COMMUNITY
EFFORTS.
DEVELOPING THESE LEADERSHIP
SKILLS AND CAPACITIES HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO PROTECT AGAINST HIGH
RISK BEHAVIORS.
AND THIRD EQUITY AND JUSTICE
NEED TO BE EMBEDDED INTO THE
PROGRAM.
AS WITH PROP SIXTY FOURS
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT GRANT
PROGRAM THE YOUTH ACCOUNT MUST
BE DESIGNED EQUITABLY WITH DEEP
INVESTMENTS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN MOST TARGETED BY
THE WAR ON DRUGS.
A SET OF POLICY DECISIONS
DESIGNED TO SYSTEMATICALLY
CRIMINALIZE PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
OUR INVESTMENTS TODAY CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN KNOWLEDGE IN
THESE WRONGS AND ENCOUNTERING
AND THE PRODUCTION OF HEALTH
INEQUITIES THAT HAS STEMMED FROM
INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM.
OUR DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE WE PUT
OUR RESOURCES AND EFFORTS
COMMUNICATE TO USE THAT WE VALUE
THEIR LEADERSHIP IN DETERMINING
WHAT WILL WORK IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THROUGH ROBUST INVESTMENTS AND
PREVENTION WE CAN HONOR AND
STRENGTHEN THE SKILLS AND
CAPACITY OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE
PART OF A COMMUNITY WIDE
SOLUTION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
A TACKLER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH
YOU TODAY I ECHO HOST EVERYTHING
THAT YOU IT JUST SAID.
I HAVE WORKED IN THE ALCOHOL
DRUG PREVENTION FIELD SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR I SERVED AS
A DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAMS
MANAGING PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
I SIT ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
UNITED STATES ANTI DOPING AGENCY
LEADING THEIR EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
AND I LEAVE THE CALIFORNIA
FRIDAY I PARTNERSHIP AT THE
TULARE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
THE CALIFORNIA FRIEND MY
PARTNERSHIP IS FUNDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND IT IS A YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM STATEWIDE
AND IT'S INCLUDED IN THEIR
STRATEGIC PLAN.
WE SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND FIFTY OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AT MORE
THAN SIX HUNDRED SITES.
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS ARE IN THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND IN NONPROFIT
AGENCIES.
AND IT'S THROUGH THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE WERE OR
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH ANDTHE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS.
ARE SEEING THE EVOLUTION OF
PREVENTION PROGRAMS FROM WELL
INTENTIONED SCARE TACTICS TO
EVIDENCE BASED YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS.
AND MY PURPOSE TODAY IS TRYING
SHARE SOME PRINCIPLES THAT WE
MAY BE ABLE TO LOOK AT TO GET
GREAT RESULTS.
COUNTY PROGRAMS FUNDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
FOLLOWS A STRATEGIC PREVENTION
FRAMEWORK PROCESS.
ASSESSING THE NEEDS AND
COMMUNITIES IDENTIFYING
STRATEGIES IMPLEMENTING THOSE
STRATEGIES AND EVALUATING HOW
WELL THEY ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THOSE.
AND RESEARCH AROUND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT HAS IDENTIFIED RISK
AND PROTECTIVE FACTORS.
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO YOUNG PEOPLE
GROWING UP TO EITHER STRUGGLE.
OR TO THRIVE.
AND SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS WILL
RELY ON EVIDENCE BASED
STRATEGIES RATHER THAN JUST
CURRICULUMS.
AND HAVE NOT YET MET A YOUNG
PERSON WHOSE LIFE HAS BEEN
CHANGED BY CURRICULA.
IS BEEN CHANGED BY THE PEOPLE
THAT THEY CAN ACT WITHIN THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE CREATE AROUND THEM.
THE FRIEND I LIE PROGRAM FOLLOWS
A SET OF STANDARDS OF PRACTICE.
THINGS THAT ARE EVIDENCE BASED
AND TO THOSE STANDARDS ARE SAFE
ENVIRONMENT BOTH PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY.
AND CARING RELATIONSHIPS.
AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE
HAVE WHEN WE HAVE NEW RESOURCES
IS THE URGE TO CREATE LOTS OF
NEW PROGRAMS.
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT WE
BUILD UPON THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE OF PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE CONTINUOUSLY LOOKING TO
IMPROVE.
AND INVEST IN THEM TO EXPAND
THEIR CAPACITY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS ON WAYS
TO ENGAGE YOUTH IN POSITIVE WAYS.
WHERE THEY BECOME PARTNERS IN
THE DESIGN OF THOSE PROGRAMS?
AND THAT THEY'RE HELPING CREATE
THE SOLUTIONS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WE FAIL MOST WHEN WE ATTEMPTED
TO APPLY ADULT MODELS TO YOUTH
ISSUES.
OUR BEST PROGRAMS ARE THOSE
PROGRAMS WHERE WE HAVE USED
VOICE IN THE DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND IN THOSE PROGRAMS WE FIND
YOUTH THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
ENGAGED.
AND HAVE SKILLS TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
STUDENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS CREATE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT BY OFFERING SUPPORT
WHEN PERFORMANCE SUFFERS.
SOON ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ARE THE
INFORM LISTENERS YOUNG PEOPLE
NEED.
THE SUPPORT FAMILY'S REQUEST AND
THE PORTAL AGENCIES REQUIRED TO
BE EFFECTIVE.
AND THE CONTINUE ON THAT WE LOOK
TO CREATE NEEDS A FULL CONTINUE
ON FROM YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES. TO STUDENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS WERE WE PROVIDES MORE
TREATMENT.
I PARTICIPATED IN THE PROP SIXTY
FOUR STAKEHOLDER GROUP WHICH IS
A GREAT EXAMPLE OF COLLABORATION.
AND COLLABORATION OFTTIMES IS AN
UNNATURAL ACT BETWEEN UNWILLING
ENTITIES.
BUT YOU HAVE THE CONSENSUS
AGREEMENT IN YOUR PACKET.
AND I'M HONORED TO SERVE ON THE
SERVICES YOUTH ADVISORY GROUP
WHERE WE'RE EMBARKING ON A
JOURNEY TO PROVIDE INPUT.
ON A CONTINUUM OF SERVICES THAT
APPROPRIATELY MEET YOUTH NEEDS
AND AGAIN MAKING SURE WE DON'T
PUT YOUTH INTO ADULT MODELS OF
CARE.
AND THAT WERE ASSURING THAT WE
HAVE YOUTH VOICE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIANS DECIDED THAT
CANNABIS USE FOR THOSE OVER
[inaudible]
TWENTY ONE IS OKAY.
BUT WE'VE ALSO WISELY DECIDED
THAT THERE IS A RESOURCE
AVAILABLE TO REDUCE THAT HARM
BECAUSE INCREASED AVAILABILITY.
AND NORMALIZATION WILL CREATE
HARPER.
AN EXAMPLE THAT NORMALIZATION IS
ALREADY HOW WE USE THE TERM
CANNABIS.
INSTEAD OF MARIJUANA.
ANYONE RECEIVING PUBLIC FUNDS TO
ADDRESS CANNABIS PROBLEMS SHOULD
BE INDEPENDENT OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
MEASURING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
PREVENTION IS CHALLENGING.
SOMETIMES WHAT WE MEASURE
DOESN'T MATTER.
AND SOMETIMES WHAT MATTERS CAN'T
BE MEASURED.
ENGAGING YOUNG PEOPLE AND
UTILIZING EVIDENCE BASED
STRATEGIES ARE BASS PATH TO
SUCCESS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SURE WITH YOU TODAY AND WELCOME
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH MISTER
DANIELS WELCOME RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY --
I'M WORKING THE DICTION
PROFESSION FOR THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS --
PRIMARILY HAPPEN NEVADA COUNTY
PLASTER COUNTY ANIMAL LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDER.
AND IN WORKING IN THOSE RURAL
COMMUNITIES --
WHAT WE'VE DEVELOPED OVER THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS?
IS WHAT WE CALL AND THE CAMPUS
MODEL AND THE CAMPUS MODEL
SUPPORTS A ROBUST COMMUNITY
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
IN ON CAMPUS WITHDRAWAL
MANAGEMENT RESIDENTIAL CARE
RECOVERY RESIDENCES.
OUTPATIENT SOCIAL SERVICES
MEDICAL NAVIGATION SUPPORT AN
AFTER CARE LICENSE METAL MEDICAL
PROVIDERS LICENSE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
CERTIFIED ISSUE DO YOU CANCERS
IN A WIDE RANGE OF SUPPORT STAFF.
THE FIRST CAMPUS WAS BUILT IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE UP IN GRASS
VALLEY AND FUNDED THROUGH A LOAN.
FROM USDA RURAL DEVELOPMENT.
AN UNLIKELY FUNDING PARTNER.
THE CAMPUS PROVIDE SERVICES TO
HUNDREDS ON A DAILY BASIS AND
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETES OVER ONE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ANNUALLY.
THE KEY ALCOVE OUR CAMPUS MODEL
THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED HAS BEEN
THE IMPACT ON THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM.
BY DRIVING CHILD UNIFICATION OF
OVER A HUNDRED CHILDREN ANNUALLY.
AS WE ALL KNOW 90% OF AMERICANS
WOULD THAT SHE DE BEGAN THEIR
USE IN THE TEN YEARS.
AND NEW WITH THAT KNOWLEDGE WE
BELIEVED IT WAS IMPERATIVE TO
DEVELOP.
PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS ADOLESCENT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
AND WE DEVELOPED A COMMUNITY
PREVENTION MODEL WHICH UTILIZES
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SCHOOLS
PROBATION SOCIAL SERVICES.
OTHER CRIMINAL JUSTICE PARTNERS --
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE --
A FULL COMPLEMENT OF PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
SERVICES TO ADOLESCENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
CURRENTLY PROVIDING SOME ARE
CURRENTLY PROVIDING SERVICES
OVER TWENTY SCHOOLS IN PLASTER
NEVADA COUNTIES.
PROVIDING EDUCATION ON ISSUE DO
YOU COPING BEHAVIORS AND DRAW IN
UTILIZING DRUG TESTING AS A
COMPLIANCE TOOL.
AND YOU MAY RECOGNIZE IN THE
ANNUAL REPORT THAT I SUBMITTED.
OUR CAMPUS MODEL ENABLES
COMMUNITIES TO EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS THE CONSTELLATION OF
COMPLICATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
INDIVIDUALS.
AND FAMILIES IMPACTED BY ISSUE
DO COST AVOIDANCE SAVINGS ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM SOCIAL HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY SPECTRUMS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
IN CLOSING I JUST LIKE TO OFFER
A FEW RECOMMENDATIONS --
THAT HAVE.
YOU KNOW THAT I'VE LEARNED ABOUT
AND IN MY LAST TWENTY YEARS AND
WORKING --
IN THIS PROFESSION.
IN THAT.
WE HAVE DRUG FREE COMMUNITY
COALITIONS OF PERRIN PLASTER
COUNTY THAT ARE FUNDED BY OWN
DCP.
AND THEY CREATE A STEERING
COMMITTEE BY TWELVE TWELVE
SECTORS IN THE COMMUNITY SOME OF
YOU MAY BE AWARE OF THAT.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO OFFER THAT
UP S A RECOMMENDATION IF YOU
INTEND TO DRIVE THAT DOWN TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL OR COUNTY AND
MARJORIE --
AND THEN THE SECOND.
ONE IS THE FUNDING MECHANISM AND
THIS IS GOING BACK AWAY ISMS ON
BEAR WITH ME THE FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT WE CREATED A PROP
THIRTY SIX BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE THAT ALLOCATED FUNDING --
TO TO THE COUNTIES --
WAS IN AGREEMENT WITH EVERYBODY
TOOK QUITE AWHILE TO COME UP
WITH THAT SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL --
BUT THAT IS A POSITIVE FUNDING
MECHANISM TO DRIVE THE FUNDS
DOWN TO THE COMMUNE TOWN THE
COUNTIES AS WELL --
THE THIRD.
THIRD RECOMMENDATION I HAVE IS --
WHEN YOU LOOK TO CREATE NEW
FACILITIES BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
NOW?
LOOK AT THE MODEL THAT WAS
DEVELOPED BY DEPARTMENT HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FOR
PROPOSITION.
FORTY SIX WHICH CREATED
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FOR HOMELESSNESS.
THIS FUNDING MODEL COULD BE
EASILY MODEL TO BUILD ALL THE
MODALITIES OF FACILITIES NEEDED
FOR ADOLESCENT CARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND LASTLY --
INSURE YOU KNOW AS A PROVIDER
AND AND AS AN EMPLOYER.
ENSURE THAT A LARGE EMPHASIS IS
PLACED ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AN ISSUE DO YOU PROFESSIONALS.
I I THINK I HEARD IT MENTIONED
ONCE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOLKS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE SPECIALIZING IN
ADOLESCENT FAMILY COUNSELING.
MARCH PET DETERMINED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THAT THE ISSUE
DO YOU WORK FORCE WAS DISTRESSED
AND NEEDED TO INCREASE
DRAMATICALLY TO MEET THE ADULT
NEED. SEVEN YEARS AGO.
OUR WORK FORCE REMAINS SERIOUSLY
DISTRESSED AND COULD NOT MEET
THE NEEDS CITIES ADDITIONAL
SERVICES WILL CREATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS --
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY YES CENTER LEYVA.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS MISS SIMMS I'D
LIKE TO START WITH YOU IF THAT'S
OKAY.
YOU TALKED ABOUT EQUITY --
WHICH I THINK IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
MY MY QUESTION IS WHAT WOULD
YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS BE FOR HOW
THE YOUTH EDUCATION ACCOUNT I'M
TO SHORTEN THAT A LITTLE BIT
SINCE IT'S KIND OF LONG --
CAN ACTUALLY STRIVE FOR RACIAL
AND ETHNIC AND SOCIAL ECONOMIC
EQUITY HOW COULD WE ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THANK YOU I'M.
SO.
INITIALLY I MEAN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT WHERE
THAT WHERE THE DOLLARS ARE GOING
CELL THINKING ABOUT WHICH
COMMUNITIES HAVE BANNED.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE WAR ON DRUGS ON WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT PIECE --
AND DEVELOPING A METHODOLOGY FOR
DOING IT WILL BE IMPORTANT --
AND THEN ANOTHER ELEMENT OF IT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ABOUT
THINKING ABOUT WHO THE MONEY
GOES TO AND WHAT IT'S USED FOR
SO.
I THINK IT'LL BE IMPORTANT TO
REALLY LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE --
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE LED BY
PEOPLE WHO YOU KNOW OUR LEVINE
AND A PART OF THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH THEY WORK.
ALSO LED BY WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR I THINK WILL BE IMPORTANT
AS WELL.
AND ADDITIONALLY REALLY LOOKING
AT KIND OF A ASSETS BASED
APPROACH TO THE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS.
I THINK YOU KNOW SERVICES ARE AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF TREATMENT --
AND LOOKING AT INVESTMENTS THAT
CAN REALLY INVEST IN COMMUNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE VERY PLACES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT KIDS NEED.
TO HAVE ACTIVITIES AND TO BUILD
SKILLS --
THOSE WILL BE IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS OF DESIGNING AN
EQUITY FOCUS PROGRAM RATHER THAN
ONE THAT'S MORE DOWNSTREAM AND
LOOKING AT TREATMENT AFTER THE
FACT.
THANK YOU THOSE VERY HELPFUL --
DOCTOR COOLER.
CAN YOU DESCRIBE YOUR FIVE HARD
EVIDENCE BASED DRUG PREVENTION.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION WE
FOCUS ON A SET OF STANDARDS OF
PRACTICE WHICH ARE.
STEEPED IN YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PRINCIPLES THE FIRST OF THOSE IS
MAKING SURE THAT ANY CONTACT
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE.
PROVIDES A SAFE ENVIRONMENT BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY.
THAT WE ALSO THAT AND TAKE A
LOOK AT DOING SKILL BUILDING
WITH THEM SO THAT THEY ARE
REALLY.
NOT JUST PARTICIPATING BUT
THEY'RE GAINING SOMETHING BY
THEIR PARTICIPATION.
WE ALSO THEN TAKE A LOOK AT
THEIR CONNECTED TO THEIR
COMMUNITY THAT THEY'RE NOT
WORKING IN ISOLATION BUT THEY'RE
CONNECTING WITH ALL THOSE AROUND
THEM.
WE ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR
BUILDING POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS
BOTH WITH THEIR PEERS.
AND WITH ADULTS AND THAT THEY'RE
INVOLVED IN ADVOCACY SO SOME OF
THOSE TYPES OF ADVOCACY WOULD
INCLUDE WORKING WITH MERCHANTS
LOCALLY SO WORKING WITH ALCOHOL
AND TOBACCO MERCHANTS ARE NOW
WORKING WITH CANNABIS MERCHANTS
AS WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
MERCHANTS
ARE RESPONSIBLE AND THEIR
BEHAVIORS AND THE COMMUNITY SO
LOOKING AT INVESTING WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO SEE AN INCREASED
AVAILABILITY BECAUSE WHERE
THERE'S INCREASED AVAILABILITY.
YOU'LL SEE INCREASE PROBLEMS SO
THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHERE TO INVEST.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE YOU'RE
HAVING MORE SALES AND MORE
AVAILABLE PRODUCT.
VERY GOOD ONE OTHER QUESTION --
YOU TALK ABOUT AVOID SUBSCRIBING
TO THE DRUG OF THE MONTH CLUB --
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT IS
EFFECTIVE --
PREVENTION STRATEGY.
BACK A REALLY GREAT QUESTION DOT.
WE HAVE A CONCERN THAT WHATEVER
SEEMS TO BE THE DRUG ABUSE TODAY
BECOMES THE FOCUS OF OUR
PREVENTION EFFORTS.
AND WHAT WE THEN MISS BY DOING
SO IS THINKING ABOUT WHY ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE NEEDING TO FEEL
DIFFERENT ABOUT WHO THEY ARE AND
WHERE THEY ARE.
SO LOOKING AT MORE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE SUPPORTS
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO THEM
GETTING TO THE ROOT CAUSES.
BECAUSE ALCOHOL IS ALWAYS THERE.
IT IS PROBABLY THE NUMBER ONE
DRUG OF CHOICE.
YET WE'LL SEE WHAT WE MAY TERM
AS EPIDEMICS ON OTHER DRUGS AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE SO VAPING
IS A HUGE ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS BECOME A BIG
ISSUE.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE
DRUGS INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES AS TO WHY
THEY'RE CHOOSING TO DO THAT.
SO OUR HOPE IS THAT IN OUR
PREVENTION EFFORTS CERTAINLY WE
WILL EDUCATE THEM ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEIR BRAINS.
THEY KNOW SOME OF THAT WE DON'T
KNOW ALL OF THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
KNOW THAT BEST OF THE RENTAL CAR
COMPANIES BECAUSE THEY WON'T
RENT A CAR TO SOMEBODY UNDER.
TWENTY FIVE THERE YOU GO.
BUT FOR THE REST OF US TRYING TO
FIND WAYS TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND HOW VULNERABLE THEY
ARE BECAUSE IN THEIR MINDS.
THERE SUPERMAN SUPERWOMAN
NOTHING CAN EVER HAPPEN TO THEM
THAT'S RIGHT SO IT'S HELPING
THEM AND HELPING THEIR FRIENDS
STEP IN SO IT ISN'T JUST AN
INDIVIDUAL DECISION.
BUT IT'S AN ENVIRONMENTAL
SUPPORT SYSTEM AROUND THEM THAT
HELPS KEEP THEM SAFE THIS GREAT
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I WANTED TO BRING IT UP PUBLICLY
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS WE TURN ON THE TV
AND IF.
YOU WANT TO BE REALLY HAPPY YOU
TAKE THIS BILL IF YOU WANT TO BE
NOT SO HAPPY YOU TAKE THAT FILL
IF YOU'RE FEELING A LITTLE
DEPRESSED YOU TAKE THIS PILL.
IS A REALLY GETTING TO THE ROOT
CAUSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING SO
LIKE YOUR BODY IMAGE WILL.
CLOSE ON AND ON AND AND WE'D
LIKE TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW CAN
WE GET TO THOSE CORE.
SUPPORTS THE YOUNG PEOPLE NEED
TO FEEL CONNECTED IT'S AMAZING
THAT E HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
COULD BE ON A CAMPUS OF FIFTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE.
AND FEEL ALONE BRIGHT CONNECTED
AND IN SOME CASES WE HAVE A REAL
ISSUE OF DISEASE OF THE HEART
THEY'RE NOT CONNECTED.
AGREED TO CONNECTING TO THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU I'VE AND
IT'S FOR YOU MISTER DANIELS --
WHAT DO YOU THINK CAN BE THAT
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MORE THAN TWO DECADES OF WORK IN
THIS FIELD IT'S IT'S HARD TO DO
BUT YOU'VE CHANGE LIVES I'M SURE
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH?
WHAT DO YOU THINK CAN BE DONE TO
PROVIDE STEP SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT TO MINORS WHO ARE
CHRONICALLY TRUANT FROM SCHOOL
OR WHOSE PARENTS ARE JUST NOT
ENGAGED?
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND
CERTAINLY ONE THAT WE HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH FOR YEARS --
AND AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL AND
WE HAVE TRIED TO CREATE SETTINGS
ON THE CAMPUS WHERE IS OUR
STUDENTS CAME --
IN WOULD GET SERVICES THROUGHOUT
THE DAY --
HAVE THE ABILITY TO COME TO OUR
CAMPUS FOR DIFFERENT SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE DAY BUT THERE HAS
NOT BEEN A CONCERTED.
PROCESS AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
TO REALLY DRILL DOWN ON THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND AND DEVELOP
A STRATEGY FOR BUT I I SEE IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT --
AS WELL AS BEING ABLE --
TO INTEGRATING INTO --
DYSFUNCTIONAL TEENAGERS FAMILY
SYSTEMS AS WELL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL.
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
CHAIR.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
OF PAYMENT RIGHT SO I'VE I HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS --
FIRST OF ALL IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW IT'S THE END OF YEARS AGO
WERE ANTICIPATING YOU
POTENTIALLY FUNDS WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH WE CAN GUESS.
HE JUST MAYBE SPEAK.
TO ANY CONVERSATIONS YOU'VE HAD --
COALITIONS HAD WITH US STATE
AGENCIES IN TERMS OF PREPARATION
TO TYPE OF FEEDBACK YOU'VE GUY
NO YOU'VE PRESENTED HERE TO US
AS WELL --
BUT IN TERMS OF YOUR
INTERACTIONS WITH DEPARTMENT
TERMS OF THE WHERE THINGS SEEM
TO BE GOING IN TERMS OF
PREPARATION FOR MAKING EFFECTIVE
USE OF THESE FUNDS.
THE QUESTIONS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROP SIXTY FOUR
STAKEHOLDERS GROUP WAS ONE OF
THE PLACES IN WHICH YOU HAD A
WIDE ARRAY OF PEOPLE COMING
TOGETHER.
AND WE DID HAVE REPRESENTATION
FROM THE DEPARTMENTS AT THOSE
MEETINGS AT TIMES --
THEY CERTAINLY WERE NOT IN A
POSITION TO MAKE ANY STATEMENTS
OR TAKE ANY POSITIONS.
BUT THEIR PRESENCE CERTAINLY
DEMONSTRATED THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO BE AWARE WHAT WAS GOING ON
AND TO HEAR WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS --
WE CONTINUE FROM OUR
RELATIONSHIP AND MANAGING
PROJECTS ITH EACH OF THE THREE
DEPARTMENTS TRY TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT THERE IS CAPACITY THAT
COULD BE EXPANDED.
AND WHEN RESOURCES BECOME
AVAILABLE HAPPY TO DO SO BUT
AGAIN TRYING NOT TO BE CUED UP
TO BE AGAIN THE DRUG OF THE
MONTH CLUB.
BY CUED UP TO WORK ON A WHOLE
RANGE OF SERVICES THAT WILL
ADDRESS.
THE UNDER AGE MARIJUANA USE AS
WELL SUBSTANCES AS WELL.
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT --
THAT CAME UP IN THE LAST PANEL
AGAIN IS THAT --
WE DON'T KNOW HOW WALL TILE THE
THE MONEY WILL BE RIGHT ONE
HOPES THAT OVER TIME WE HAVE AN
EXPECTED AMOUNT BUT IT'S
POSSIBLE.
THAT YOU COULD SEE VERY A SWINGS
BECAUSE THE WAY THE MONEY FLOWS
RIGHT PART ONE PART TWO FINALLY
DOWN TO THIS ONE SO YOU CATCH
WHATEVER'S LEFT RIGHT SO COULD
BE A LOT ONE YEAR IT'S POSSIBLE
MIGHT DECLINE ANOTHER.
MAYBE AND WE DON'T KNOW THIS CAN
BE CORRELATED ECONOMY OR NOT HOW
MUCH EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW HOW LARGE THE BLACK
MARKET GETS OR SHRINKS OR SO
FORTH.
SO.
FROM.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE I KNOW YOU
SPOKE MORE PRESSURE PROGRAMMATIC
LEE BUT HOW DO YOU THINK WE
SHOULD HANDLE THIS OUR ADDRESS
THIS --
POSSIBILITY OF VERY ABILITY
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT WORKFORCE
RIGHT WELL YOU IT'S NOT LIKE --
WHAT'S ONE YEAR WE CAN SELL THE
RAMP UP THE PROGRAM AND TRAIN A
WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE AND THEN.
DOWNSIZE IT --
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE NO MONEY OR
WELL.
SO HOW IT HOW HOW THIS HOW HOW
WOULD YOU SEE --
THAT THAT WE HANDLE THIS
VOLATILITY AND SOME PEOPLE SAY
WELL TO MOVE ALL THE MONEY ON
THE STREET RIGHT AWAY RIGHT --
BUT THEN YOU COULD HAVE THESE
REALLY BIG SWINGS OR SOME PEOPLE
SAY WELL LET'S BUILD UP AT A
RESERVE AND SAY THAT WE'RE GONNA
SO THAT WE CAN KEEP TO SETTLE
LOOKS MORE STEADY LEVEL MAYBE
LOWER LEVEL BUT AGAIN WE HAVE TO
SORT OF GUESS A LITTLE BIT.
SO WITH EVERY SOME THOUGHTS
ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD HANDLE THE
THAT THE DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS
IN RELATION TO THE VOLATILITY OF
POTENTIAL VOLATILITY I DON'T
KNOW THE SOURCE.
ALL THIS THROUGHOUT A COUPLE
COMMENTS OUT THERE I THINK THIS
NEEDS A HIGH LEVEL STRATEGIC
PLAN OKAY --
AND AND EACH ONE OF THOSE --
COMPARTMENTS ENTERED IN A FIRE
WITHIN AT STRATEGIC PLAN
TIMELINE AND ROLLED OUT.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IF WE
TRAIN OF THE WORK FORCE TODAY WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THE FACILITIES. TO
GET THE FACILITIES WE HAVE A A
REGULATORY QUAGMIRE ESPECIALLY
WAS RESIDENTIAL --
AND DETOXIFICATION SERVICES --
THAT CURRENTLY IN VERY DIFFICULT
FOR PROVIDERS TO NAVIGATE SO WE
NEED.
TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THAT
SO MY MY RECOMMENDATION IS A
HIGH LEVEL STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
TIME LINE.
AND THEN WE JUST ROLLED OUT
BASED ON THOSE DECISIONS --
WELL I RECOGNIZE YOUR ASKING
PARTIALLY KINDA HOW TO YOU KNOW
HOW DOES THE PROGRAM OPERATE
QUESTION --
AND I THINK OUR HOW YOU THINK
YOU SHOULD ARE HOW I THINK IT'S
OVER DISCUSS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IT'S RELATED TO THAT WHICH
IS -- ONE I
MEAN WE STRUGGLE WITH THIS WITH
YOU KNOW BEING FOUNDATION FUNDED.
OFTEN ALL OF THE TIME AND I KNOW
AND THAT KIND OF TOBACCO CONTROL
WORLD ALSO REVENUES HAVE BEEN
YOU KNOW SLOWLY DECLINING OVER
THE YEARS --
ONE THING I'D SAY IS THAT WE
REALLY DO A LOT TO FOCUS THE
PROGRAMMATIC EFFORTS ON BUILDING
SUSTAINABILITY WITHIN
COMMUNITIES SO.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT JUST.
PEOPLE KEEP COMING THROUGH THE
DOOR AND WE KEEP NEEDING TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES OVER AND
OVER AGAIN BUT HOW DO WE DESIGN
THE PROGRAM.
SO THAT WERE BUILDING LEADERSHIP
OVER THE LONG TERM TO ADDRESS
THIS AND A HOST OF ISSUES.
THAT AFFECT COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
WELL BEING AND THEN HOW DO WE
BUILD THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAS A LONGER
YOU KNOW SHELF LIFE.
AND THEN YOU KNOW THAT THE FUNDS
FROM YEAR TO YEAR SO I THINK
THAT'LL BE AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
ATTIC ELEMENT.
AND I WOULD TAKE --
MAYBE A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
AND ONE THAT WILL BE HEARD
ANYONE ELSE'S I HOPE THERE IS NO
MONEY AVAILABLE I HOPE THAT OUR
PREVENTION PROGRAMS ARE SO GOOD.
THAT THE REVENUES ARE NOT HIGH
ENOUGH THAT WE INVEST IN THIS
CATEGORY.
BEING THAT THAT PROBABLY WILL
NOT BE THE CASE.
I WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT PROBABLY A TWO TO
THREE YEAR LAG TIME.
BEFORE YOU SEE ENOUGH REVENUE TO
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST NOT PUTTING
OUT DRIBBLING SMALL AMOUNTS BUT
WAITING UNTIL YOU CAN DO
SOMETHING CORRECTLY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT YOUR
INVESTMENT CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
WHAT WE LIKE TO SEE IS A
MOVEMENT RATHER THAN MOMENTS WE
CAN PUT A LITTLE BIT SOME MONEY
OUT AND CREATE OF BATS?
BUT EVENTS WON'T CREATE A
MOVEMENT NOR CHANGE SOCIAL NORMS.
SO MY RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
IF YOU HAVE ONLY A SMALL AMOUNT
DO SMALL PILOT PROJECTS.
BUT THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
THAT CHOOSE AND AGAIN I HOPE
THAT OUR PREVENTION PROGRAMS ARE
SO GOOD.
THAT WE'LL SEE AN INITIAL BUBBLE
AND THEN THAT WAS FINDINGS WILL
BE REDUCED.
AND I KNOW WE HAVE THE THREE OF
YOU HERE WILL PREPARE FOR SOME
MORE PEOPLE IN PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS
THERE.
WELL IN ANY COALITION --
MAY HAVE THE DESERVE GENERAL
AGREEMENT IN TERMS OF DIRECTION
ON HOW WE SHOULD BE AS THE WE
HAVE THE AGENCIES COMING UP
RIGHT AFTER YOU BUT IN TERMS OF
VERY STAKEHOLDERS AND STIR SOME
IS.
THERE HOW MUCH DIVISION --
AGREEMENT IS THERE ABOUT HOW WE
SHOULD --
HOW HOW WE SHOULD ADDRESS NOW
THIS --
SPENDS MONEY.
I THINK YOU'RE STAKEHOLDERS
GROUP IS PROBABLY YOUR BEST
CONSENSUS DOCUMENTS OKAY THERE
ARE MANY AREAS WHERE THERE IS
NOT CONSENSUS THE PRIMARY ONE
WILL BE HOW MUCH MONEY DO INVEST
IN TREATMENT.
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU INVEST IN IN
PREVENTION?
THAT IS A DYNAMIC TENSION THAT
SEEMS TO NEVER GO AWAY.
YOU'LL NEVER HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO TREAT EVERYONE WHO IS IN NEED-OF TREATMENT AND IF YOU DON'T
INVEST ENOUGH IN PREVENTION.
YOU'LL KEEP GETTING MORE PEOPLE
IN NEED OF TREATMENT FOREVER
DEBATING THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT AND
WHERE YOU PUT IT BUT PERHAPS WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT MECHANISM TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF DISCUSSION YES
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
YES YOU THERE HAS ALSO BEEN --
BUT ED CONSENSUS DOCUMENT PUT
TOGETHER BY A GROUP OF
ORGANIZATIONS LOOKING AT TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACHES AND I'M
BLANKING ON THE NAME OF THAT
IT'S A LONG ACRONYM BUT I'M SURE
THOSE SOME OF THOSE WHO WILL BE --
PROVIDING COMMENT MAY KNOW THE
NAME OF IT --
AND I THINK THAT WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT PIECE TO LOOK AT AS
WELL BECAUSE IT KIND OF TALK
THROUGH THE DIFFERENT --
APPROACHES THAT COULD BE TAKEN
AND THE WAY THEY CAN BE REALLY --
A TAILORED IN A WAY TO BE TRAUMA
INFORMED.
AND THEN FINALLY --
BECAUSE WE ARE HAVING THE
AGENCY'S COME UP AFTER YOU AND
WE DID THAT.
INTENTIONALLY BECAUSE WE WANT TO
BE SURE THAT --
THEY HEARD WHAT YOU SAID AND
ALSO PERHAPS RESPONDED --
WHAT KIND OF QUESTIONS DO YOU
THINK THAT I SHOULD?
WE SHOULD BE ASKING THEM OR
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THAT WE
WOULD THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM THE AGENCIES --
CENTER PAN OWN.
YOU KNOW.
FROM A PROVIDER'S PERSPECTIVE
THE REGULATORY PROCESS OF
LICENSING --
IS EXTREMELY CHALLENGING AND I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO WORK THROUGH AS WELL.
THE CAMPUS THAT I TALK TO YOU
ABOUT --
JUST IN OUR OUTPATIENT PROGRAM
SERVICES TO THE THE FULL BREADTH
OF THE COMMUNITY --
OR LICENSED AND CERTIFIED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH OR LICENSED AND
CERTIFIED FOR ISSUE DE WERE
LICENSED AND CERTIFIED IN FOUR
OR FIVE DIFFERENT AREAS.
ALL TO DRIVE SERVICES AT A ONE
AREAS SO COLLECTIVELY HOW DO WE
MAKE TO REGULATORY PROCESS
EASIER FOR PROVIDERS TO APPLY
AND IT HERE [inaudible]
TO I'M.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PREVENTION --
WE NOTICES THAT --
FUNDING STREAMS OFTEN GET SILO
TO YOU KNOW TO DEALWITH
PARTICULAR DISEASE STATE SEN YOU
KNOW THIS --
ONE I THINK WE REALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF VERSUS TO
THAT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND I
KNOW THERE IS.
YOU BASED ON THE PROPOSITION
LANGUAGE OF FOCUS ON SUBSTANCE
USE AND AND YOUTH I THINK THAT
LEAVES A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY --
TO REALLY TAKE LESSONS FROM
OTHER SILENT PROGRAMS AND DESIGN
IT IN A WAY THAT --
ALLOWS FOR FLEXIBILITY AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL AND I'D LIKE
TECH KIND OF HERE YOU KNOW HERE
FROM THE DEPARTMENTS ABOUT HOW
THAT WILL BE APPROACHED I THINK
THAT'LL BE A CRITICAL PIECE.
I THINK ITS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE FROM SILOS TO SYNERGY --
WE SEE GREAT PROGRAMS IN EACH OF
THE THREE DEPARTMENTS AND IT'S
THE CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THEM
THAT ARE SOMETIMES DIFFICULT.
YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T SEE THE
DIFFERENCES AND WHERE THE MONEY
COMES FROM.
ALL THEY SEE IS WHAT KIND OF
SERVICES AVAILABLE WHAT KIND OF
SUPPORTS CAN I BE A PART OUT.
SO IT'S GETTING THOSE.
GUERRILLAS IN THE LIVING ROOM TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
WORK TOGETHER IT'S NOT EASY.
THEIR HUGE SYSTEMS AND EACH HAS
CREATED WONDERFUL WAYS TO
DISSEMINATE RESOURCES THROUGH
THEIR INDIVIDUAL SILO AND THE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THEM.
ARE ALWAYS CHALLENGING.
THIS CREATES AT OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD ON THE GOOD PRO AS AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO CONNECT THEM
BETTER.
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY.
ARE BETTER AT DOING THAT THAN
THOSE AT THE HIGHER LEVELS.
SO LOOK TO COMMUNITIES AND ASK
THEM HOW DO WE LINK THOSE
TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING.
RIGHT THANK YOU --
AT THAT THEN THE FAN AND OUT.
SO -- AGAIN
THANK YOU ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID
BECAUSE AND IS THAT --
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ME WE
HAVE A FUND THAT WE OFTEN HEAR
WHO WE HAVE FUNDS PARTS DOWN
SILOS RIGHT MAY HAVE FEDERAL
MONEY TO HAVE TO GO CERTAIN
PLACES AT CETERA.
WE ALSO SENATE'S HAVE FUNDS
DIVIDED UP SO VERTICALLY
HORIZONTALLY VERTICAL SILOS WILL
THIS IS HEALTH CARE MY
DISSERTATION THIS IS YOU KNOW
SUBSTANCE USE.
THAT.
MENTAL HEALTH WHATEVER AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE A SLICE HORIZONTALLY EIGHT
STATE FEDERAL MONEY STATE HAS TO
GO TO COUNTY YOU KNOW SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHATEVER.
AND WHILE CERTAINLY THERE'S A
REASON WE HAVE THINGS ORGAN THAT
IS THE FIGURE OUT WHAT'S MOST
AFFECTED SO I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU BROUGHT UP SO.
A SENATOR ALSO.
I JUST WANT --
TO SAM REALLY GLAD TO HEAR I
KNOW YOU ALL MENTIONED SOME
VERSION OF THIS BUT DOCTOR
COOLEY USE PACIFIC LEE TALKED-ABOUT.
BUILDING UPON EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND EXPANDING CAPACITY I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT WAY TO
GO AND TO BE THAT KIND OF LIKE.
OF WILL REFER TO IS NOT JUST THE
SERVICES BUT WHAT DO YOU
BUILDING AS FAR AS ORGANIZATION
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY --
BECAUSE SERVICES CAN COME AND GO
THEY COULD CHANGE BUT WHAT STAYS
THERE WHAT DO YOU CREATE THAT
PERMANENT.
THAT THAT COMMUNITY CAN RELY ON
AND THAT WE EMPOWER THEM.
NOT JUST YOU KNOW BE THE
SAVIOURS WALK IN AND WE'RE GOING
TO DO THIS AND THAT AND WE'LL
TAKE CARE OF IT ALL FOR YOU.
AND IT IS MUCH HARDER TO BUILD.
SOME REAL ORGANIZATION BUILD
THIS REAL CONNECTED
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE EVERYBODY'S
COMMITTED.
NOT YOU KNOW OKAY WHERE THE
DOLLARS COME FROM WHO'S GOING TO
GET THE DOLLARS WILL I WANT THE
DOLLARS A RATHER --
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR PLACE IT'S
OKAY TO BE.
I WILL USE THE WORD SILO AGAIN
BUT IT'S OAK IT'S OKAY TO HAVE
YOUR EXPERTISE OR A PARTICULAR
PLACE THAT YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON
BUT IT HAS.
TO COME ALL CONNECTED BUT I DID
WAS SAY APPRECIATE THAT POINT OF
VIEW AND IT REMINDS ME --
THAT WE HAVE TO DESIGN AND CRAFT
SOME OF THESE IDEAS THANK YOU
MUCH LIKE A PUZZLE YOU HAVE NEED
ALL THE PIECES TO GET THE WHOLE
PICTURE.
ANY OTHER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS --
REALLY APPRECIATED I WOULD JUST
MAKE NOTE TO OUT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT TO BE A SIGN UP SHEET SO
WE'LL BE DOING THAT AFTER NEXT
PANEL.
SO JUST --
BUT SERGEANTS SO PLEASE SIGN UP
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT I KNOW WHEN IT WILL COME
UP.
OUR OUR DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS WHO
WERE INVITED TO A FAULT IN
IMPLEMENTATION --
DIRECTOR JENNIFER KENT'S OF THE
PART HEALTH CARE SERVICES --
DOCTOR KAREN SMITH WHO'S OUR
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE PART PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND I CAME JACKSON DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE PART
EDUCATION WELCOME.
AND APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU BEING
HERE AND TO SHARE AND TO SHARE
WITH US --
WHAT WORK HAS TAKEN PLACE SO FAR
WHAT DO --
TO MAKE EFFECTIVE USE OF THESE
FUNDS WHICH WERE HOPING BASED ON
WHAT FINANCE TOLD US WE WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
PEOPLE OUT WITH.
SO WITH THAT --
AND IF YOU HAVE AN OREO AGO AND
OKAY WILL GO HEAD START WITH THE
PARTS OF THE HEALTHCARE SPACE
YEAH WELCOME THANK YOU SO MUCH --
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE'VE DONE
TO DATE --
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES --
CITY PH.
HAS THAT WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
TO DROPS THE THERE WAS AN
INITIAL FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
CARVE OUT A PROPOSITION. SIXTY
FOUR FOR IT WITH ONE TIME
FUNDING TO ESTABLISH AN INFANT
IMPLEMENTED A PUBLIC INFORMATION --
CAMPAIGN AND IT OUTLINED VERY
SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT NEEDED TO
BE ADDRESSED IN THAT CAMPAIGN WE
INTRODUCED TO THE I A WITH DH CS
FOR FOUR MILLION DOLLARS --
TO ADDRESS THE SPECIFICS IN PROP
SIXTY FOUR PROVIDING BASIC
PROVISIONS OF THE LAW AND THE
ASSOCIATED PENALTIES.
SCIENTIFIC BASIS FOR RESTRICTING
YOUTH ACCESS TO CANNABIS AND THE
POTENTIAL HARMS OF USING
CANNABIS TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS INCLUDING BREAK
PREGNANT AND BREASTFEEDING WOMEN
AND YOUTH --
WE DEVELOPED FOR SCIENCE BE
SUBPOPULATION CAMPAIGNS ONE FOR
ADULTS AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
ONE FOR PREGNANT BREAST FEEDING
WOMEN AND ONE FOR YOUTH AND ON
ADDITIONAL ONE FOR PARENTS AND
MENTORS OF YOUTH.
AND WE LAUNCH --
WHAT WE TERMED THE LET'S TALK
CANNABIS CAMPAIGN ON TIME ON
SEPTEMBER FIRST?
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE GOAL OVER
ALL WAS SEN UNDERSTAND THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS OF CANNABIS
LEGALIZATION.
WITH SPECIFIC GOALS FOR EACH OF
THE SUB POPULATIONS FOR THE OVER
TWENTY ONE THE GOAL WAS TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH --
SCIENTIFIC CAN'T BASED
INFORMATION THAT THEY COULD USE
IN DECIDING FOR THEMSELVES HOW
TO RESPONSIBLY USE OR NOT USE
CANNABIS. FOR PREGNANT BREAST
FEEDING WOMEN AND FOR YOUTH BOTH
THE GOAL REALLY WAS TO DELAY OR
PREVENT CANNABIS USE.
AND OR OVER USE IN BECAUSE BOTH
OF THOSE POPULATIONS HAVE
SPECIAL RISK FACTORS WITHOUT FOR
PARENTS AND MENTORS IT WAS TO
GIVE THEM THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEIR WHAT THE YOUTH WITH WHOM
THEY WORK AND OR LIVE ARE.
AT RISK FOR AND HOW TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
SO -- IN TO
A WE DID A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
FORMATIVE RESEARCH PRIOR TO
DOING THIS SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND
THE LAY OF THE LAND AS FAR AS
BELIEFS AND ATTITUDES AND WHAT
INFORMATION WAS ACTUALLY OUT
THERE -- FOR
EACH OF THESE POPULATION GROUPS
AND WE DEVELOPED THAN VERY
SPECIFIC AND CULTURALLY
CONGRUENT HEALTH COMMUNICATIONS
FOR THE EACH OF THOSE CAMP OUT
EACH OF THOSE ASPECTS OF THE
CAMPAIGN --
WE INCLUDED --
SO WHAT IT ENDED UP WHAT WE
ENDED UP DEVELOPING IS OF A
ROBUST WEBSITE --
AND THEN FOR EACH SUB POPULATION
OF THIRTY SECONDS --
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
CUSTOM JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT IN A MINUTE.
SOCIAL MEDIA ASSETS TIP SHEETS
AND DATA FAQS --
FACT SHEETS ALL OF WHICH ARE IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH --
TO SUPPORT IN BILL THAN THE
CAPACITY OF OUR PARTNERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE IS A FAIRLY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY IN A VERY
LARGE STATE AND EACH.
PART OF THE STATE HAS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT MAKE UP AS FAR AS
THOSE GROUPS THAT ARE VULNERABLE
WE DEVELOPED --
A SET OF LET'S TALK CANNABIS
CAMPAIGN MATERIALS WERE FULLY
CUSTOMIZABLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SO THAT PEOPLE COULD DEVELOP
THINGS THAT ACTUALLY ADDRESSED
THEIR PRIORITIES IN WAYS THAT
THEIR COMMUNITY WOULD COULD
RELATE.
TO THOSE MATERIALS REMAIN
AVAILABLE AT THIS TIME.
WE HAD MONTHLY CALLS WITH OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS AS WELL TO TALK
ABOUT UPDATES ON THE CAMPAIGN
BUT ALSO.
WHAT WE WERE FINDING FOR
RESEARCH AND IS NEWS RESEARCH --
DEVELOPED AND TO ANSWER ANY OF
THEIR QUESTIONS WE WERE WE WERE
ARE VERY HAPPY WITH HOW WELL
RECEIVED.
THE THE CAMPAIGN WAS IN THE WAY
THAT IT HELPED DISSEMINATE SORT
OF CONSISTENT MESSAGING ACROSS
THE STATE --
AND THEN FINALLY WE CONDUCTED
DIGITAL AND TRADITIONAL MEDIA --
PLACEMENT OF FOR ALL OF OUR
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS AM
HAD A YOU TUBE CHANNEL DEVELOPED
AND ALSO THROUGH ONE OF HIS
YOUNG.
OVERALL WE HAD A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FIVE FIFTY MILLION
IMPRESSIONS GARNERED OVER TWENTY
FOUR MILLION VIDEO COMPLETIONS
AND OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TV SPOTS --
AND WHICH WERE BROADCAST ON
INTERVIEWS YOU DIEGO AND SO WE
FEEL LIKE WE REALLY HAVE MADE A
GOOD START ON THE INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN --
USING THE MATERIAL THE THE
FUNDING THAT WAS AVAILABLE FROM
THE BEGINNING.
KAMALA TURN IT OVER TO JENNIFER.
THIS POINT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CAN.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH --
SO I WANTED --
TO BOTH HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
AGENDA PREPARED BY YOUR STAFF --
JUST TO SUPPLEMENT IN ADDITION
TO THE WORK THAT WE AS A
DEPARTMENT HAVE TO AND IN THE
DRUG MEDI CAL ORGANIZED DELIVERY
SYSTEM --
THE CREATION OF THAT THE WORK
WITH THE COUNTY SO --
TO CREATE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE --
FOR THOSE THAT ARE NOT QUITE AS
FAMILIAR ON IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM --
WITH OUR TWENTY FIFTEEN MEDICAID
IT WAS THE RE AUTHORIZATION OF A
SYSTEM OF CARE THAT HAD NEVER
EXISTED IN ANY OTHER STATE
MEDICAID PROGRAM SO WE WERE THE
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY TO CREATE.
A TRUE --
CONTINUUM OF CARE ACROSS ALL THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER BROADLY RIGHT FROM
MEDICAID POPULATION AND SO FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
WE WERE ABLE TO OFFER PEOPLE ALL
THE WAY UP FROM VOLUNTARY
INPATIENT DETOX SERVICES DOWN TO
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
OUTPATIENT INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT
MEDICAID ASSISTED TREATMENT.
SO GREEN --
SERVICES AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THE THE RIGHT IT CERTAINLY --
ACKNOWLEDGES THE WORK
INFRASTRUCTURE AND KIND OF
ONGOING FUNDING COMMITMENTS THAT
WE'VE MADE WITH THE COUNTIES ON
THAT -- WE
HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME RECIPIENT
FOR THE SAFTEY BLOCK GRANT SO
THIS IS THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT BLOCK
GRANT THAT COMES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE SEND THOSE MONIES DOWN TO THE
COUNTIES THEY USE THOSE 80% --
CAN BE USED FOR SERVICES 20% CAN
BE USE FOR PREVENTION --
WE HAVE SLIGHTLY CHANGE HOW --
THOSE FUNDS ARE BOTH DISTRIBUTED
AND SO INSTEAD OF JUST THE MONEY
INSANE TELL US WHAT YOU DID WITH
IT WE'RE NOW DOING IT WE HAVE
SWITCHED IT SUCH THAT IT'S AN
INVOICING TYPE OF THING WHICH IS
TELL US WHAT YOU DID WITH THE
MONEY AND THEN WE WILL PAY.
YOU WANNA INVOICE AS OPPOSED TO
A DIRECT --
FUND -- THE
THING I REALLY WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT AND I THINK THIS
REALLY DEMONSTRATE SOME OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE'VE CREATED
AND ADDRESSES THE DRUG OF CHOICE
COMMENTS --
ON THE PRIOR PANEL IS WE HAVE
RECEIVED --
TWO SETS OF SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
FUNDS --
RELATED TO OPIOIDS SO THE CARERS
ACT PROVIDED US WITH NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS
AND THEN THE OPIOID TARGETED
RESPONSE GRANT --
IS ABOUT A HUNDRED IN. FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS
AND THAT IS REALLY FOR STATES TO
USE AND A VARIETY OF WAYS TO
HELP ADDRESS THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW GETTING
BACK AND STEP IN A LITTLE BIT
AWAY FROM THAT WE HAVE TRIED
VERY HARD --
TO WORK ACROSS DIFFERENT --
DEPARTMENTS AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY ORGANISER WE BUILD NOT
ONLY IN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WHICH
THE FEDERAL GRANTS ARE DIRECTLY
SUPPOSED TO BE USED FOR RIGHT
BECAUSE THE GRANT SAY YOU HAVE
TO USE THIS FOR OPIOID WORK.
BUT WE'VE TAKEN KIND OF A LONGER
RANGE PERSPECTIVE WHICH IS ARE
WE ABLE TO HELP BUILD CAPACITY
AND OTHER AREAS AND SO.
I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
HIGHLIGHT SPECIFICALLY AROUND
THE U. STUFF --
WHEN YOU TAKE ALL THOSE MONIES?
WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS --
ACROSS THE SCOPE OF BOTH OF
THOSE FEDERAL GRANTS --
RANGING FROM NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION SO OBVIOUSLY A HUGE
AMOUNT OF THAT IS JUST GETTING --
NALOXONE INTO THE HANDS OF
LIBRARIES IN JAILS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT --
BUT WE ALSO HAVE FUNDED --
DRUG AND ALCOHOL COUNSELLORS IN
RURAL EMERGENCY ROOMS WE HAVE
FUNDED --
HOSPITALS MORE BROADLY --
FOR SERVICES IN THE ER SUCH THAT
WHEN PEOPLE COME AND THERE'S AN
ABILITY TO KIND OF WORK WITH
THEM ON A IMMEDIATE BASIS AND
PRESCRIBE --
MEDIC LIKELY DONE SOME TARGETED --
WORK WITH THE TRIBAL POPULATIONS
BECAUSE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
EITHER OPIOID MISUSE OR OVERDOSE
RATES ARE TRIBAL POPULATIONS ARE.
TWO TO THREE FOUR TIMES HIGHER
THAN THE REST --
WE HAVE PROJECTS FOR OR NEONATAL
ABSTINENCE SYNDROME AND WE HAVE
DESIGNED SOME PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS FOR AT RISK YOUTH --
AND THEN APPEAR SUPPORT ARE YOU
SPACE RECOVERY SERVICE --
TYPES OF PROJECTS I THINK
BROADLY ARE BOTH GOAL WITH THIS
FUNDING AS WELL AS OUR INTENTION
AND WORKING WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS IS TO NOT JUST
ADDRESS THE CURRENT ISSUE AROUND
OPIOIDS.
BUT ALSO BUILD CAPACITY SO THAT
IT IS FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS --
MORE BROADLY.
I THINK WHEN YOU THEN --
STEP INTO THE PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR FUNDING AND THIS
OPPORTUNITY --
FOR A SPECIFIC SET OF FUNDING
COMING FROM A DIFFERENT FUND
SOURCE THAT IS REALLY --
ALMOST --
UNLIMITED IN ITS POTENTIAL --
IT HAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS
IN WHICH THE INITIATIVE SAYS YOU
COULD FIND THIS BUT IT ALSO IS
PROGRESSIVE RIGHT YOU MADE DO
THESE FUNDING.
OPPORTUNITIES BUT YOU COULD ALSO
DO OTHER THINGS AND I THINK WE
ARE LOOKING AT THIS MORE BROADLY
IS HOW DO WE BOTH WORK TOGETHER
BUT WAY THAT WE ARE TARGETING
USE AND FOCUSING MOST
EFFECTIVELY ON PREVENTION
THERE'S NOT AS MUCH FUNDING.
AND PREVENTION EVER RIGHT I'M A
I'M A BIG PROGRAM THAT DOES A
LOT OF HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM TYPES OF EXPENDITURES BUT
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF PREVENTION
DOLLARS IN MEDICAID AND SO I
THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS FROM
A MORE COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
BUT ALSO VERY MUCH DRAWING.
ON THE PREVENTION EDUCATION
EARLY INTERVENTION SIDE OF THE
FUND AND SO I THINK YOU TO THE
EXTENT THAT FINANCE --
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY INDICATED
THIS IS A GOING TO BE A MAY
BUDGET PROPOSAL SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL CERTAINLY
KIND OF BE GEARED IN THAT AREA
WHICH IS HOW DO WE DO SOMETHING.
TO CERTAINLY --
CAPTURE --
CHILDREN WHERE THEY ARE --
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHERE THE
EDUCATION --
INTERAGENCY ALIGNMENT COMES IN
AS WELL AS IN OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH SO.
HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS AFTER
THAT.
THANK YOU SUPERINTENDENT DANIELS.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN MY NAME IS KIND
JACKSON DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF IT --
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF ST --
PUBLIC SUPERINTENDENT A TONY
THURMOND I'M HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS STEPHANIE PAPPAS.
AND I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED SO
FAR ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROP PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR AND OF FOR SO I'LL
DISCUSS THE LAN SOME OF THE
SENTIMENTS OF OUR AGENCY
PARTNERS HERE --
ONE OF THE LENS AS WE APPROACH
THIS IS THROUGH THE WHOLE SCHOOL
WHOLE COMMUNITY WHOLE CHILD
APPROACH TO INCLUDE A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM STRATEGY.
AND THE MAINTENANCE OF
APPROPRIATE AND ADEQUATE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS WE ALSO
LOOK AT THIS THROUGH THE LENS OF
PRIORITIZING THE CONCEPT OF
PREVENTION WELLNESS AND EARLY
INTERVENTIONS IN SCHOOLS.
AND SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES WE
HAVE THE INTENT OF COLLABORATION
OF COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND WE ALSO HAVE LOOKING AT THIS
THROUGH THE LENS OF DEVELOPMENT
AND MAINTENANCE OF TEARS SYSTEMS
OF SUPPORT WHICH ALL WHICH
INCLUDE ALL LEVELS OF PREVENTION.
AND EARLY INTERVENTIONS. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION STARTED
WORKING ON THIS ACTUALLY BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SO THAT WE WERE PREPARED AND
POSTURE TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS.
SHOULD THEY SHOULD ANYTHING
ARISE IN TERMS OF CONCERNS FROM
PARENTS.
OF FOR THE IMPENDING ADULT USE
OF RECREATIONAL CANNABIS AND
WHEN IT BECAME LEGAL.
THE FIRST STEP TO INITIATE IT
WILL WEB PAGES WHICH CONTAIN
LINKS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY.
YOUTH RISK BEHAVIOR STUDIES
WHICH REPORTED USAGE RATES LINKS
WITH RESEARCH VALIDATED
PREVENTION MATERIALS AND
RESOURCES FOR PARENTS AND SCHOOL
PERSONNEL ONE SUCH RESOURCE WAS
A LINK.
WITH MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
STUDENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE DESIGNED. TO INTERVENE
WITH STUDENTS WHO ARE DISPLAY
CONCERNING BEHAVIORS.
ANOTHER THING THAT WE DID IN THE
DEPARTMENT WAS CONVENE AN
INTERNAL DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
STAKEHOLDER WORK GROUP
CONSISTING OF LEADERS
CONSULTANTS AND ANALYSTS FROM
PROGRAM AREAS WHICH WE THOUGHT
ARE LIKELY TO BE RECIPIENTS OF
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR REVENUE.
INCLUDED BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION FOR
HEALTH RELATED CAREERS AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AND PARENTING%
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT AND EARLY
LITERACY DROP OUT PREVENTION.
STUDENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTHNEEDS
SCHOOL SAFETY IN BOWLING
PREVENTION.
AND ADDITIONALLY SCHOOL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
INCLUDING COUNSELORS NURSES AND
LIBRARIANS MISSION IS SPEAKING
WITH OTHER STATES DEPARTMENTS OF
EDUCATION SUCH AS COLORADO AND
WASHINGTON FOR THE PAST YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT IN OUR STAFF HAVE
BEEN PARTICIPATING IN AN
EXTERNAL PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
STEAK OR STAKEHOLDER ROGUE
GROUPS WHICH YOU'VE HEARD.
SOME OF OUR PARTNERS MENTION
BEFORE.
AND PART OF THOSE MEMBERS ARE
CALIFORNIA FIRST FIVE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND MANY MANY MORE.
THIS GROUP HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY
TO CREATE A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE ISSUED
THIS PAST FALL TO LAWMAKERS ON
HOW TO BEST IMPLEMENT
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FUNDS.
THE CITY HAS VAST EXPERIENCE IN
AREAS OF PREVENTION.
AN INTERVENTION STUDENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED HERE TODAY.
AND WERE MENTIONED IN THE
PROPOSITION.
AND THE CITY HAS BEEN A
PROPONENT OF STUDENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE AN EFFECTIVE
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
STRATEGY NOT ONLY FOR DRUG AND
ALCOHOL USE.
BUT ALSO --
USE WITH STUDENTS WHO ARE
DISPLAYING --
BEHAVIORS OF CONCERN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
TOBACCO USE PREVENTION EDUCATION
PROGRAM PROVIDES A MODEL OF
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
THIS PROGRAM FOCUSES ITS EFFORTS
ON REDUCING RATES OF TOBACCO OR
NICOTINE USE AND THE USE OF
VAPING DEVICES WHICH WE'VE HEARD
TODAY IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
ONLINE CANNABIS IS CURRENTLY NOT
A TOBACCO PROGRAM FOCUS BUT THE
PROGRAM HAS ACHIEVED SUCCESS IN
CITIES SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING
SMOKING.
SMOKING AND NICOTINE USE AMONG --
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WITHIN
FUNDING.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THESE FUNDS TARGET HIGH RISK USE
PROVIDE PEER TO PEER MENTOR SHIP
PROGRAMS PROVIDE THE USE OF
RESEARCH VALIDATED.
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
THE TOOLS NEEDED TO BUILD
POSITIVE SCHOOL CLIMATES.
THE CITY UNDERSTANDS THAT A KEY
COMPONENT OF FUNDING ALLOCATION
IS DETERMINING WHETHER THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING EFFECTIVE.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE FOR ONGOING
STUDIES WITH STATE UNIVERSITIES
AND RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS TO
CONFIRM PROGRAM EFFECTIVENESS.
THE GRANTEES ARE CLOSELY
MONITORED MUCH ANNUALLY EVALUATE
THEIR PREVENTION PROGRAMS IN
SUBMIT STATUS REPORTS TO
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THROUGH OUR CURRENT WORK ON
TOBACCO PREVENTION AND OUR
PREVIOUS WORK ON DRUG ALCOHOL
PREVENTION.
WE'VE LEARNED THAT PREVENTION
EDUCATION ABOUT PARTICULAR DRUGS
IS IMPORTANT.
THE KEY PART OF PREVENTION
EDUCATION IS AN EMPHASIS ON
REFUSAL SKILLS.
DECISION MAKING SKILLS AND
PERCEPTION OF ARM.
SWING CLOSING I SHARE THESE DE
THESE DETAILED INFORMATION WITH
YOU ABOUT THE SUCCESS OF OUR
TOBACCO PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
AND THE WORKS WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED
SO FAR TO DEMONSTRATE THAT WE
ARE DEDICATED TO USING
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FUNDS
EFFECTIVELY.
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES
A CRITICAL NEW REVENUE STREAM
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO USING
THESE FUNDS TO EDUCATE YOUTH.
AND FAMILIES ABOUT THE CONCERNS
OF UNDER AGE AND NON MEDICAL USE
OF CANNABIS WHILE REDUCING THE
STIGMA.
OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES TREATMENT
AND RECOVERY THANK YOU.
SO MUCH THE BURDEN JACKSON START
OKAY -- ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
YES CENTER LEYVA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE --
I WANT TO START WITH YOU MS
CAN'T -- THE
ADULT USE MARIJUANA ACT PASSED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AS WE
ALL KNOW.
RUMOR HAS IT THAT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
SERVICES.
HAS NOT TEEN ANY FORMAL CONTACT
WITH THE P. AGENCY D. E. TO
DEVELOP AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT --
AS IS REQUIRED SO IS THAT TRUE
AND IF SO WHY.
SURE SO I THINK --
WHEN THE ACT WAS PASSED --
AND WE WERE AWARE THAT THERE
WERE NOT FUNDS BEING MADE IT
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE I THINK
THAT WE WE'RE DOING YOU KNOW
OTHER.
ACTIVITIES RIGHT WE'VE BEEN
DOING A TON OF STUFF ON OPIOIDS
AND I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE AND
WE DID AN INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT
FOR THE FIRST FIVE MILLION.
SO THERE WAS SOME CONTACT BOTH
WITH DPH NOT NECESSARILY SEE
EITHER BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
FUNDS AVAILABLE I THINK THAT.
WE DO INTER AGENCY AGREEMENTS
WITH EACH OTHER AND A VARIETY OF
WAYS AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
MAY PROPOSAL --
PART AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET KIND OF OUTLINES.
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW THE
GOVERNOR WOULD I SEE THOSE FUNDS
BEING SPENT WE WOULD BE WORKING
ON INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS A KIND
OF CONFORM WITH THAT.
OVERALL.
DESIGN SO I THINK IT WAS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT WE WERE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET AHEAD OF
EITHER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION IN WHICH
DECISIONS HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT
HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
SPENT BECAUSE THEY SENT.
SIMPLY WEREN'T AVAILABLE AND NOW
THAT WE'RE STILL AITING FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF WHAT THOSE FUNDS
WILL LOOK LIKE THEN WE WOULD
WORK ON INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS
TO KIND OF CONFORM WITH THAT
PROPOSAL.
YES GOOD --
I WANT TO ADD TO THAT WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY VERY CLOSELY
TOGETHER AND COORDINATING VERY
CLOSELY OUR ACTIVITIES IN TERMS
OF BUILDING --
BOTH PREVENTION AND TREATMENT
USE IT UNDER USING LEVERAGING
QUITE FRANKLY THE OPIATE MANY
SIT BUT BUT ALSO.
ACTUALLY ACTIVELY SITTING DOWN
AT A TABLE AND SAYING SORT OF
WHERE IS YOUR EXPERTISE WHERE IS
OUR EXPERTISE.
TO DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE ARE
GETTING SILOS MANY WERE ACTUALLY
CROSSING OVER AND AND SORT OF
COURSE TRADING WHILE YOU'RE
REALLY MUCH BETTER IF YOU KNOW
DETAILING WITH PHYSICIANS WERE
MUCH BETTER IT BUILDING.
DATA SYSTEMS AN EVALUATION OR
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS AND SO
LITERALLY --
ON AS THESE FINE AND WE'RE JUST
FEDERAL AGENCIES WITH DIFFERENT
SPECIFICS WERE ACTUALLY CREATING
A VERY INTEGRATED.
SYSTEM THAT.
IS FOCUSED ON EXACTLY THE SAME
THING IT'S NOT THE DRUG OF
CHOICE WE'RE NOT BUILDING
EXCLUSIVELY CERTAIN ASPECTS ARE
NALOXONE FOR EXAMPLE DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE A ROLE.
EXCEPT THAT IT'S BUILDINGFOR US
A NETWORK OF PARTNERS WITHIN
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES WHO WILL
BE WORKING WITH US AROUND
REPORTING CANNABIS YOU KNOW
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES FROM CANNABIS
IT CETERA AND SO.
I THINK THAT WHILE WE DIDN'T
HAVEN'T BEEN DEVELOPING SPECIFIC --
I. A.'S WE HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
LEARNING HOW TO WORK TOGETHER
AND HAVE REALLY GOOD MODELS NOW
ON HOW WE FIGURE OUT.
YOU GUYS DO SCHOOLS REALLY WELL
YOU DO HEALTHCARE FACILITIES WE
DO WE SUPPORT COALITIONS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND GOVERNMENT
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY FOCUSED ON
OPIATES BUT WON'T ALWAYS BE.
AND GETTING THOSE COSS SECTOR
PARTNERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS
CAN BE CRITICAL TO US GETTING
ACTUALLY REALLY GOOD TRACTION.
IN PREVENTING CANNABIS OVER USE
IN YOUTH FRANKLY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT SO WHAT.
ARE YOU READY TO HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING I MEAN I I GUESS MY
WORRY IS THAT THAT PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THERE'S BEEN
TWO YEARS --
YOU'RE RIGHT EVERYBODY HAS THEIR
EXPERTISE BUT ARE YOU GUYS READY
ONCE NOW THE FUNDING IS COMING
DO YOU HAVE A PLAN HEAVY SET
PRIORITIES.
HAVE YOU IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES --
TO HAVE NEAR AND LONG TERM GOALS
MY MY CONCERN IS THAT THE THESE
THINGS HAPPEN AND THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION.
THAT WHEN WE'RE DOING OUR JOB
YOU GUYS ARE KIND SOMETIMES WE
FIND OUT THAT'S NOT TRUE.
RIGHT AND I THINK --
AGAIN JUST YOU KNOW TO BACK TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
OVERALL STATEMENT IN TERMS OF TO
THE EXTENT THAT FUNDS ARE BEING
APPROPRIATED IN THIS BUCKET --
THREE SOME OF THE PART OF THE
NAY REVISION WILL KIND OF SHOW
YOU SOME OF THE WORK AND
THINKING AND GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES THAT WE OURSELVES
HAVE THOUGHT OF AS AND THAT WILL
BE PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IN MAY AND SO I CAN YOU
SHARE THAT WITH US.
COULD NOT YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT
IS THE IT IS THE PART OF THE
GOVERNOR AND TERMINATE HISMAY
PROPOSAL BUT I THINK THAT IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD.
PROPOSE AND SAY HERE'S THE TIME
FRAME FOR THE EXPENDITURE OF
THOSE FUNDS HERE'S WHAT THOSE
FUNDS WOULD BE IN A PROPOSED TO
BE.
PORTION OUT OF YOU KNOW IN
CERTAIN WAYS AND THESE ARE THE
WAYS THAT WE WOULD BE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP
DEVELOP EITHER --
THE EXPENDITURE OR THAT PROCESS
AND SO I THINK ALL OF THAT IS
STILL --
UNDER THE DEVELOPMENT --
BETWEEN US THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATION BUT
IT WOULD CERTAINLY BE AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
IN MAY.
SO WE CAN SHARE THAT WHEN IT IS
RELEASED PUBLICLY DO FEEL LIKE
YOU HAVE A PLAN.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE --
OUR BEST THINKING AND THOUGHTS
AND THAT THOSE ARE BEING PUT
THROUGH THE INTERNAL IT
MINISTRATION BUDGET DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS TO CLOSE TO A PLAN.
SURE YES.
I JUST WERE JUST YOU KNOW THIS
IS A BIG DEAL I I I WAS OF
LEGALIZING MARIJUANA --
BECAUSE I WORRY THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE READY AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE RIGHT
PREVENTION--
IN PLACE SO IT'S IT'S YOU GUYS
HAVE A REALLY BIG JOB AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT OUR YOUTH THAT'S ALL
WELL AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THE INITIATIVE IN ADDITION TO
REQUIRING THE I. A.'S ALSO
REQUIRES A STAKEHOLDER.
PROCESS SO SOMETIMES --
EVEN IF WE HAD AS THREE
DEPARTMENT SAID THIS IS HOW THE
I. A.'S SHOULD WORK BETWEEN US.
IT'S COMPLETELY CONCEIVABLE THAT
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WOULD
COME AND SAY NO WE DON'T AGREE
RIGHT AND YOU WOULD COR YOU
WOULD GET FEEDBACK OR YOU WOULD
GET EXPERTISE FROM A DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATION OUR PARTNER WHERE
THEY SAY YOU SHOULD THINK ABOUT
IT THIS WAY AND SO I WOULD SAY.
THAT THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS MAY FLOW
TOGETHER BASED ON BOTH YOU KNOW
I THINK WE TRY VERY MUCH AS AS
WE CAN TO ACHIEVE A CONSENSUS
BASED.
PROPOSAL BUT CERTAINLY NEED THE
EXTERNAL PROCESS TO CONFIRM THAT
DECISION AS WELL AND SO I. A.'S
BETWEEN US ARE ALSO GOING TO BE
KIND OF INCOME AND ON THERE
BEING AN EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS FOR WHICH THAT FLOWS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S MADE ME
PROPOSAL.
AND THAT COULDN'T START UNTIL
NOW.
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP WHEN WE
COULD HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WELL I THINK IN SOME CASES THE
AT WE HAVE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS SEES THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AT THE DEPARTMENT --
WE HAVE BROAD STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
WE HAVE USE ADVISORY GROUPS WE
HAVE INTERAGENCY PREVENTION.
COUNCILS WE HAVE --
A LOT OF DIFFERENT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH STAKEHOLDER GROUPS I
THINK YOU KNOW WITHIN MY
DEPARTMENT ALONE NOT TO SPEAK TO
YOUR DEPARTMENT --
I PROBABLY HAVE THIRTY OR FORTY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS THESE WORKGROUPS
ADVISORY COMMITTEES AT ANY GIVEN
TIME AND SO I THINK THAT --
WE HAVE SOME THINKING WE
CERTAINLY HAVE EXISTING
PREVENTION PROGRAMS WE HAVE
EXISTING PREVENTION CONTRACTS --
AND ADVISORY GROUPS AND SO ALL
OF THAT IS GOING INTO DEVELOPING
THE THINKING FOR THIS NEW FUND
SOURCE AS WELL AS HOW DO WE KIND
OF BOTH STRENGTH IN OUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I THINK AGAIN --
DOCTOR COOLEY REFERENCES AS WELL
AS WE HAVE CAPACITY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE HAVE BUILT WE
HAVE KNOWN PROGRAMS WE HAVE
KNOWN --
PARTNERS AND SO YOU KNOW YOUR
FIRST STEP AS A DEPARTMENT IS TO
LOOK AND SAY DO I NEED TO RE
CREATE SOMETHING AND I THINK
THAT THAT IS CERTAINLY PART OF
THE THINKING THAT IS UNDER WAY
WITHIN.
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION THE OTHER
THING FOR US IS TO IS BEING
CAREFUL THAT WE'RE ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THAT STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS SYSTEM PART IS WE HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND NOT JUST WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO BUT WHAT IS THEIR
CAPACITY.
BECAUSE WE WON'T BE DOING MOST
OF THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
OBVIOUSLY IT WILL BE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND SO.
BUT HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH ABSOLUTELY HOW MUCH
AVAILABLE BECOMES VERY SORT OF
HIGH LEVEL AND FUZZY AND NOT
SOMETHING YOU REALLY WANT TO
MAKE PEOPLE DO INTENSIVELY AND
CREATE A PLAN THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT ACTUALLY WORK.
I'M JUST SORT OF HEARING ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE THINGS
THAT YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT ON
WEIGHING IN ON HOW THE PROCESS
SHOULD WORK THREE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE WOULDN'T WANT TO GET TOO FAR
DOWN THE ROAD CREATING
UNINTENTIONAL EXPECTATIONS THAT
WE THEN CAN'T FOLLOW THROUGH ON
WHICH ISN'T SAY WE'RE NOT HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE WE
ARE BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE HIGHER
LEVEL CONVERSATIONS RATHER THAN
BEING THE DETAILED.
CONVERSATION.
OKAY THANK YOU BOTH.
THANK YOU --
AT I HAVE TO SAY THAT CHAIRS --
MAY THE SAME CONCERNS A CENTER
LEYVA ABOUT IN TERMS OF TIMING
WISE -- BE
SURE THAT --
WERE HAVING THE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS WE NEED TO HELP.
GET THIS OFF THE GROUND SO THAT
IT'S NOT LIKE WHILE WE WAITED
TILL THE MONEY SHOWED UP NOW WE
HAVE THE MONEY NOW WERE.
MARCH MORRELL AND NOTHING
HAPPENS RIGHT PEOPLE ARE GONNA
SAY WELL GEE YOU KNOW WHAT WERE
YOU DOING WITH THIS --
AND SO -- I
APPRECIATE THAT --
THERE'S A EFFORT TO GET
SOMETHING BY MAY REVISE.
MY OTHER HAT CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR SOMETHING BEFORE THEN NOT
AND NOW F. ONE MAY HITS THERE'S
A LOT NOT A LOT OF TIME BETWEEN
MAY AND WHEN WE HAVE TO GET THE
FINAL BUDGET.
NOW RECOGNIZING THAT WE WON'T
ACTUALLY REALLY KNOW HOW MUCH
MONEY I GUESS WE JUST TOLD A
FINANCE UNTIL AUGUST BUT YOU
KNOW I THINK.
CERTAINLY THERE SHOULD BE MUCH
MORE OF AN OUTLINE ABOUT WHERE I
APPRECIATE THAT TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT FOR STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUP
IN TERMS OF GETTING DOWN TO
SERVE THE PRESS TAX YOU KNOW YOU
DO WANT TO HAVE AN IDEA WHEN AND
SO FORTH --
THAT WOULD MEAN JUST GIVE ME
SOME CHALLENGES VOLATILITY TOO
SO WE'LL KNOW HOW MUCH FOR ONE
YEAR RATE WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
THE YEAR AFTER RIGHT SO AND AND
AND BUT I THINK THERE ARE
PERHAPS SOME CONVERSATIONS THAT
CAN ALREADY BE HAD WE RE RAISE
SOME OF THEM.
RIGHT HERE IN THIS HEARING ABOUT.
SO STAKEHOLDERS --
KNOWING THAT WE WILL ONLY KNOW
ONE YOUR DOORS MONEY WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE NEXT YEARS WILL BE --
IS GOING TO GO UP SAY THE SAME
GO DOWN --
THAT HOW DO YOU WANT TO HANDLE
THIS WE HEARD SOME FEEDBACK
ABOUT WELL MAYBE WHAT WE DO IS
IN ORDER TO QUOTE MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WE NEEDED TO HIT A
CERTAIN AMOUNT SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY PUSH A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
SERVICE OUT RIGHT SO DO WE DO WE
HAVE.
SOME KIND OF SO SOME OF THOSE
KIND OF DISCUSSIONS.
GUESTS AND THE END OF THE BAR
HEALTHCARE SERVICE VERY LARGE
I'M SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR WITH THE
YOU MENTIONED ALL THE STATE OVER
THE BUT ALL THE STAKEHLDER
GROUPS ARE.
DEALING WITH THIS FUN DIRTY IN
THIS OR EVEN WITH USE RIGHT --
SO.
SO WHAT KIND OF CONVERSATIONS
ARE YOU CRRENTLY HAVING WITH
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR FUND [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
SO I MEAN I'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROGRAMS RE
DOING AND THERE'S A WONDERFUL
RIGHT AROUND A FEW AIDS AND AND
EDUCATION AND SO FORTH AND I
THINK THOSE INFORMED WHAT WE
WANT TO TRY TO DO WITH THIS AND
AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT.
WE DON'T TREAT THIS AS A
SEPARATE SILO THAT'S COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM EVERYTHING ELSE
WHO I CONNECTED SO I APPRECIATE
THAT PRESENTATION.
BUT I'M ALSO FOR THIS HEARING.
WHERE WOULD YOU SEE THIS FUND
FIT AND WHAT'S THE CT AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IS THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT HOW?
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THIS YOU
KNOW GREAT OPERA TIONS SO
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY IT'S OF SOME
UNCERTAIN AMOUNTS IT'S PROBABLY
NOT AT THE SCALE NECESSARILY O
SOME OF THE OTHER FUNDS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE POSSIBLY I DON'T KNOW
WE DON'T KNOW BUT PROBABLY TO
ASSUME IT'S NOT GONNA BE QUITE.
THAT LARGE BUT IF THEY CAN BE
VERY NIMBLE POTENTIALLY
POTENTIALLY RIGHT BECAUSE THE
LACK OF RESTRICTIONS SO DOLLARS
WE DON'T --
SO WHAT ARE SOME OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE BEING HAD WITH
STAKEHOLDERS A NOW ABOUT WHAT A
WHOLE WHERE'S THIS FATTY OF THIS
KIND OF MONEY BEST FIT. TO SPEAK
FOR OUR DEPARTMENT --
WE HAVE HAD FROM THE THERE EVEN
BEFORE PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
PASSED AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
WITH OUR PARTNERS PARTICULARLY
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS BUT
ALSO.
YOU KNOW THE THE NONPROFIT AND
FOUNDATIONS ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
CANNABIS AND WHAT IS WHAT IS
PREVENTION THAT IS SEPARATE FROM
TREATMENT.
AND FOR US SPECIFICALLY WE DON'T
WANT.
TO SOMETHING THAT VETS
DUPLICATIVE BECAUSE IT IMPACTS
OF THIS USED TO SERVICES IN IN
PART OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES BUT
PUBLIC HEALTH DOES.
HAVE SORT OF STANDARD ROLES IN
ISSUES LIKE THIS INCLUDES THINGS
LIKE THE ACQUISITION ANALYSIS OF
DATA MONITORING EVALUATION --
PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS
ETCETERA AND SO WE'VE HAD VERY --
GENERAL CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
IS IT IN TERMS OF THAT THOSE OF
US IN THE IN THE BROADER PUBLIC
HEALTH ARENA.
THINK IS OUR LIKELY TO BE OUR
ROLE SHOULD FINDING BECOME
AVAILABLE AND WHAT DO PEOPLE
REALLY WANT TO SEE AND SO THOSE
ARE THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY HAVING.
AND THEY ARE INFORMING OUR
CONVERSATIONS IT REALLY DOES
COME OUT WHAT IS IT THAT.
AFTER THAT WE WANT TO DO WITHOUT
FUNDING AND WHO ARE WHO WE WANT
TO ENGAGE IN THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WHERE.
THE GENERAL CONVERSATIONS LEAD
TO THE MUCH MORE SPECIFIC ONCE
ONCE WE HAVE THE I. A.'S AND WE
KNOW WHO'S DOING WHAT.
SURE AND I WOULD SAY THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
BOTH -- WITH
ME PERSONALLY AND AS WELL AS MY
STAFF IN VARIOUS FORUMS AND
MEETINGS AND CONFERENCES --
WE HAVE CERTAINLY HEARD FROM
FOLKS THEY'RE THINKING IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW CERTAINLY A LOT OF
GROUPS HAVE REALLY --
BEEN PREDOMINATELY PUSHING A
PREVENTION FOCUS --
YOU KNOW PHILOSOPHY SLASH YOU
KNOW AND IMPERATIVE AND I THINK
THAT WE WOULD AGREE BROADLY WITH
THAT BEING.
PART OF KIND OF A DELIBERATE OF
PROCESS FROM THE STANDPOINT THAT
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
COMMIT.
TO I THINK THAT WE HAVE HEARD
AND BASED ON THE PREVIOUS PANELS --
POINT IS THAT THERE IS A STRONG
TENSION BETWEEN TREATMENT AND
PREVENTION AND SO THERE ARE
DYNAMICS --
FROM THE EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS
THAT -- ARE
LEANING AND THEN CERTAINLY THE
SCHOOLS --
WOULD BE A THIRD DYNAMIC IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW IS IS IT A
PREVENTION OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOLS AS A PREVENTION WITHIN
THE SCHOOLS AND THEN YOU
CERTAINLY HAVE A TREATMENT.
PROVIDER CAPACITY SO I THINK WE
HAVE IN THE MEETINGS AND
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
HAVE BEEN MORE IN A RECEPTIVE
TELL US YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND
THOUGHTS --
I CERTAINLY WOULD AGREE WITH
BOTH THE ELLIE OWES RIGHT UP AS
WELL AS THE SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
PERSPECTIVES ON LEARNING LESSONS
AROUND OTHER TYPES OF VOLATILE
FUNDS SOURCES SO WE ALSO
ADMINISTER THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WE ALSO ADMINISTER
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX WE ALSO.
HAVE A DEAF A LOT OF DIFFERENT
VOLATILE FUND SOURCES THAT ARE
NOT NECESSARILY TIED TO THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM AND I WOULD
AGREE THAT A LOT OF THOSE
LESSONS THAT WERE NOTED IN THE
MATERIALS.
ARE CERTAINLY THINGS THAT WE
OURSELVES HAVE BOTH AS SEEN IN
AGREED WITH AND I THINK THAT ALL
KIND OF INFORMS.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
DEVELOPING FOR YOU KNOW FOR
PURPOSES OF THAT OF THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS HIS NEW ADMINISTRATION
TEAM.
I I LET MY COLLEAGUE STEPHANIE
PROVIDE SOME OF THE DETAIL BUT
WE WOULD WE WOULD AGREE THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS LOOKING AT THIS FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE WHAT WHERE ARE
WE WHERE WE GOING.
HOW WE'RE GONNA GET THERE WHAT
ARE WE GONNA DO WHEN WE GET
THERE?
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF MECHANISMS
ALREADY IN PLACES AS DEPUTY
JACKSON SAID --
AND THE STRUCTURES BEEN BUILT
THROUGH OUR TOBACCO PREVENTION
PROGRAM BUT WE ALSO HAVE
PROCESSES THAT INVITE REQUIRE
ACTUALLY STAKEHOLDER
PARTICIPATION THROUGH THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANNING.
PROCESS AND ALSO THE SCHOOL SAFE
PROCESS BOTH OF THOSE --
HAVE EXISTING REQUIREMENTS TO
INCLUDE THE COMMUNITY AND TO
INCLUDE PARENTS AND GUARDIANS
RESIDENTS OF THIS I HAVE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS BEEN HAD IT THOSE
THAT THOSE TYPE PROGRAMS ON THIS
PARTICULAR THE U. PIZZA I GUESS
SO.
THAT MY ATTEMPT TO TRY TO TURN
THIS PUMPING INTO AN ACRONYM --
THOSE FUNDS SO I RECOGNIZE YOU
HAVE THOSE MECHANISMS IN PLACE
FOR STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
AROUND THESE OTHER ISSUES BUT
I'M A PARTICULAR CARES ABOUT
WHAT CONVERSATIONS HAD EVERY ARE.
CURRENTLY HAPPENING ARE HAPPENED
THE PAST SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THIS
FUND AND HOW WE SHOULD.
USE THESE FUNDS.
I BELIEVE IN YOUR PACKAGE IS THE
THE LETTER THE SUMMARY LETTER OF
THE EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS GROUP
THAT WE PARTICIPATED IN THAT.
DOCTOR COOLER MENTIONED IN AND
OUT --
DEPUTY JACKSON MENTIONED OUR
INTERNAL CONVERSATIONS AS WELL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT NOW. 889-8 I CERTAINLY --
DO I RECOGNIZE --
DIRECTOR CAN YOU SAID THAT
PREVENTION MONIES USUALLY THE
HARDER ONE TO GET TO SO WHAT WE
HAVE THIS TENSION --
THAT --
CERTAINLY WILL BE SURE THAT --
PREVENTION IS SOMETHING THAT --
WE ADEQUATELY FUND AND HOW WE
FIT THIS AND I PUT AGAIN PRE
SHEET PRESENTATION ABOUT THE
OTHER ACTIVITIES BECAUSE THIS IS
A STANDALONE THIS SHE DID THAT
AND HOPEFULLY HELP US LEVERAGE.
OTHER BOTH ACTIVITIES OUR
FINDINGS --
SOURCES THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE --
TO TO LEVERAGE SO WHETHER IT'S
ON EDUCATION OR HEALTH OR PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND OTHER GRANTS AND OTHER
STATES PROGRAMS FIRM AND I
FAILED TO MENTION AS WELL AS I
THINK YOU KNOW LOOKING ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM --
CERTAINLY.
IT YOU KNOW THERE'S ALSO
PROPOSALS IN THE IN THE BUDGET
AROUND TRYING TO SCREENING FOR
BOTH PEDIATRIC AND ADULT
POPULATIONS.
I THINK THAT --
WE'RE TRYING REALLY HARD TO KIND
OF CONSISTENTLY --
LOOK IN TERMS OF THE INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE BEING MADE AND HOW THEY
KIND OF INTER LINK WITH EACH
OTHER AND SO YOU KNOW.
THOSE ARE ALL KIND OF YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY NOT BEING TAKEN AND I
SILLY SOON WITH EACH OTHER AND
SO -- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
AS WELL AS IT PERTAINS TO THE
TRAUMA SCREENS.
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE HOW ARE YOU
BUILDING THE SERVICES AND
CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THESE --
SPECIFIC DEDICATED FUNDS BECAUSE
CERTAINLY HELP EITHER STRETCH OR
INCREASE THE CAPACITY OF THE
THAT ARE ALSO BEING PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MANSION.
PAYING WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING --
FIGURE YOU NEED SOME TIME TO
WORK ON THIS MORE EXTENDED
SCOTIAN ABOUT THIS MATTER BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
THANK YOU ARE LEYVA.
THANK YOU.
I HAD HOPED TO COME HERE TODAY
AND HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
AND A CLEAR PICTURE OF WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING WHAT YOU GUYS
BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS -- BUT
I I HAVE TO SAY I FEEL LIKE IT'S
ABOUT AS CLEAR AS MUD.
SO I HOPE THAT NGUYEN --
THE GOVERNOR'S A MAY REVISE
COMES OUT I HOPE THERE IS SOME
SORT OF A PLAN AND FRAMEWORK
THERE SO THAT THE I WILL ONLY
SPEAK FOR MYSELF.
DON'T FEL LIKE NOT MUCH HAS
BEEN HAPPENING FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND AND I'LL JUST SAY
AGAIN.
IS A REALLY BIG DEAL THE VOTERS
PASSED THIS WHETHER WE WANT
MARIJUANA TO BE LEGAL OR NOT --
ISN'T UP TO US OUR JOB IS TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE KEEPING OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE SAFE MAKE SURE THAT
WERE PREVENTING --
PEOPLE FROM USING MARIJUANA AND
AND IT'S A BIG JOB AND I JUST
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE NOT TAKING
IT SERIOUSLY.
BUT IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS AND I
HAVE FIFTEEN PEOPLE O MY STAFF
AND I'M AMAZED AT HOW MUCH THEY
CAN GET DONE.
SO HOPE YOU CAN FIND SOMEBODY ON
STAFF TO WORK ON THIS --
AND MAYBE SOMEBODY --
SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
AT THE YOU SAID THIRTY OR FORTY
ALWAYS WORKING YOU MAY BE ONE OF
THEM CAN START WORKING ON THIS
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE MAY
REVISE AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO YOU I'D SAY ANYTHING I CAN DO
TO HELP BUT I THINK YOU GUYS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HANDLE IT SO
THANK YOU.
WHAT THAT I WANT THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE WE LOOK FORWARD --
TO THE FOLLOW UP.
ON THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASED TO HAVE THE DIRECTORS OF
TWO DEPARTMENTS AND OUR DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT HERE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO --
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT --
NORMALLY JUST HAVE PEOPLE LINED
UP AT THE MICROPHONE BACK THERE --
I DO I KNOW I HAVE A LIST HERE.
I THINK IT'S I COULD TRY CALLING
UP PEOPLE'S NAMES OF MAYBE IT'S
BEST YOU KNOW WHO YOU'RE ON THE
LIST SO WE WE DO WHAT IT --
SO IF YOU JUST WANT TO LINE UP
AT THAT MICROPHONE OVER THERE --
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT
TO BE SO I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
YOU COULD TRY TO CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS TO A MINUTES.
RIGHT YES THE AND IF SOMEONE
ELSE SAID SOMETHING YOU AGREE
WITH YOU CAN SAY ME TOO I AGREE.
TO AND WE WITH THE AND WE'LL
TAKE THAT AS WELL SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THESE START OFF WITH
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND LOOK
FOR IT AND WE SHE CUTS THANK YOU.
ARIANNA I GUESS WE ARE THANK YOU
AT SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS TO DATE ON WHAT
THE STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN DOING FOR THE PAST TWO
YEARS ON RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
WORK FORCE --
WE TRY TO BRING IN AS MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS AS WE COULD FROM
EDUCATION AND FROM PREVENTION
AND FROM TREATMENT.
KNOWING THAT ALL OF THESE ARE
DIFFERENT WORK ENVIRONMENTS ARE
ALL REGULATED BY DIFFERENT --
TO ENTITIES IN STATE GOVERNMENT
SO WHAT WE CAME UP WITH WAS A
ONE AND FIVE YEAR PLAN FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HERE ONE
CONSISTS OF THE MUCH NEEDED
STUDY OF THE WORK FORCE.
AND ALL MODALITIES IN SCHOOLS
AND ALSO IN AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND TREATMENT
PROGRAMS WHAT IS THE SKILL LEVEL
AND QUALITY OF THE WORK FORCE.
WHERE THEY LOCATED WHERE THEY
BEING PAID OR THE BEING
REGULATED ACCORDINGLY TO BE SAFE
FOR FOR USE COMING INTO
TREATMENT?
AND THEN YEARS TWO THROUGH FIVE
WOULD BE MORE OF THE NUTS AND
BOLTS GIVEN THE INFORMATION
COMES OUT OF THAT YOU'RE ONE
STUDY. TO DO THINGS LIKE LOAN
REIMBURSEMENT --
EVALUATING WHETHER PROGRAMS ARE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT WHETHER
THEY'RE LGBT Q. FRIENDLY WHETHER
OR WE'RE LACKING --
SOME DIVERSITY ARE CANCERS
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME LANGUAGE
DEFICIENCIES AND CHARTING --
SOME BASIC SKILLS AND ENGLISH
LANGUAGE THAT COULD BE.
GIVEN TO THE WORK FORCE TO HELP
THEM.
SO I WOULD URGE COMMITTEE MAYBE
TO THE MOB AS A STARTING POINT
SINCE FOR TWO YEARS TO NATIONS
TOGETHER THANK YOU MAKE NOTE
THAT -- WE
HAVE REPORTS RIGHT PLEASE SEND
THEM TO AND EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WE WE KNOW THAT GIVE A SHORT
TIME TO SPEAK HERE BUT WE WE WE
ARE WE WERE VERY INSTANCE
INFORMATION THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU A DOCTOR LYNN SILVER
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN --
A PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE IN
UCSF DIRECTING GETTING RIGHT
FROM THE START OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SOME
MATERIALS ARE BEING PROVIDED TO
YOU -- ARE
KEEP MY KEY FOCUS ON THIS IS TO
SAY THAT OUR STATE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK IS CURRENTLY DEVELOPED
HAS BEEN GROSSLY NEGLIGENT IN
THE PROTECTION ABUSE.
FROM UP PREDATORY PRACTICES OF
THE INDUSTRY THAT ARE COPYING
TOBACCO --
IN REGARD TO USE THIS IS AN
URGENT PREVENTION REGULATORY
CHALLENGE THAT CAN BE SUPPORTED
IN THE DRESS THROUGH THE YOUTH
PREVENTION FUNDS THROUGH VERY
SMALL STRATEGIC.
INVESTMENTS TO LOOK AT THESE
ISSUES JUST TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY BAND
FLAVORED CANNABIS --
THE BCC PROMPTLY ISSUED A
REGULATION ASSURING DELIVERY OF
ANY PRODUCT ANYWHERE --
UNDERMINING LOCAL CONTROL ON THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO PROTECT YOU --
I WON'T GET INTO ALL THE DETAILS
BUT FIRST THE FUN NEEDS TO START
FLOWING.
I RECOMMEND AND WE RECOMMEND
THAT --
PERHAPS TWO THIRDS OF THE FUND
BE USED FOR PREVENTION FOR
SUSTAINED COMMUNITY BASED CHANGE
ON THE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT FROM OTHERS
SPEAKERS --
THESE ARE AREAS THAT DO NOT HAVE
OTHER FUNDING FLOWS I WOULD ASK
THAT THE SMALL STRATEGIC
INVESTMENT BE GIVEN TO THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. TO
STUDY SPECIFIC ISSUES LIKE
POTENCY FLAVORED PRODUCTS AND
OTHERS THAT ARE BEING USED TO
ATTRACT YOUTH AND RECOMMEND
APPROPRIATE REGULATORY PRACTICES --
AS WELL AS THE OTHER TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT OUT
I'D ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU.
YOU THIRTY THREE MUCH WELCOME
THAT AFTERNOON I'M THE UNDER
CARD HARVEY THE DIRECTOR POLICY
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES --
WE ARE PART OF THE PROP SIXTY
FOUR WORK GROUP AND IT'S REALLY
BEEN A REALLY GREAT PROCESS
WE'VE HAD A DOCUMENT THAT'S BEEN
DISTRIBUTED TO YOU.
AND WE JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK AT THAT --
AND THE RECOMMENDATION SENATE --
ALL --
ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WITH
THE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN IMPLEMENTATION TO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE ON THE DICE TODAY --
AND ALSO WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE CURRENTLY IS NO
SYSTEM OF CARE FOR YOU SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO FOCUS ON
TREATMENT WE UNDERSTAND IT'S
GONNA BE A BATTLE BETWEEN WHAT
PERCENT IS TREATMENT WHAT
PERCENT AS A PREVENTION --
BUT AS A REPRESENTATIVE FOR
PROVIDERS WE BELIEVE THAT WERE
THE FOLKS THAT ARE.
BEST PREPARED TO DO THIS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO I'M SIR MICHAEL JACKSON
AND I'M WITH YOU FORWARD A
JULIET SIMMS TOUCH ON THIS TODAY
BUT WHEN ALLOCATING THESE NEW
FINDS I URGE YOU TO TAKE.
A RACIAL EQUITY IN PREVENTATIVE
HEALTH PERSPECTIVE CONSIDER THE
WELL BEING OF HONORABLE YOUTH
AND YOUTH OF COLOR THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM THEIR INVESTMENT OF
MORE SUPPORTS.
I ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO INCLUDE
THE VOICES OF CHILDREN AND YOUNG
PEOPLE ON WHAT SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS.
THEY NEED OUT OF THESE REVENUES.
YOU FORWARD BELIEVES THAT WHEN
ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT DIRECTLY
IMPACT YOU.
THE VOICE IS THE VOICE AND
PERSPECTIVE OF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
KEY TO DEVELOPING SOLUTIONS THAT
WORK.
THANK YOU THANK THROUGH MUCH
WELCOME AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA TO KNOW
WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK --
WE WOULD A LINER COMMENTS AT THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS JUST STATED --
IN THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
AN EQUITY ISSUE AND WE FEEL THAT --
AS WE UNDERSCORE THIS AS SUCH A
MANY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE AT
RECOGNIZING CHILDHOOD TRAUMA --
WE TALK ABOUT TYPES OF METHODS
THAT WERE USING--
AND CONTRIBUTING FUNDS TORE
HIGHLIGHT THE NEEDS FOR EVIDENCE
BASED AND COMMUNITY APPROVED
APPROACHES --
ONE OF WHICH IS S. BIRD WHICH IS
THE SCREENING BRIEF INTERVENTION
AND REFERRAL TO TREATMENT
PROGRAM SO THIS CAN BE DONE IN A
SCHOOL SETTING IT OPENS A
DIALOGUE UP WITH STUDENTS
AND REALLY ALLOWS --
EDUCATORS TO REALLY GET AT THE
HEART OF WHAT THE THE BASES ARE
FOR SUBSTANCE USE AND
EXPERIMENTATION SO WE HOPE THAT
THROUGH THE PROP SIXTY FOUR OF
CANNABIS REVENUES WE CAN.
FULLY FIND OUT PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT IN CALIFORNIA AS IT'S BEEN
DONE IN OTHER STATES THANK YOU
SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TRACY
MENDEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE
UNFORTUNATE TO BUILD ON MANY
PRIOR COMMENTS --
AND IN TERMS OF BUILDING ON THE
EXISTING CAPACITY INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN THE STATE CALIFORNIA HAS
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
LOCATED OFTEN IN.
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE WAR ON DRUGS AND
CRIMINALIZATION.
SO WE'RE EXCITED --
TO BUILD ON THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
THE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS --
ARE --
OPERATED AS A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS AND THEY OFFER A
VARIETY OF HEALTH AND BE HER ALL
SERVICES IN AN INTEGRATED LOCAL
ACCESSIBLE YOUTH FRIENDLY
SETTING.
AND THEY ADDRESS --
AND PROVIDE MANY SERVICES --
CONTINUUM THAT YOU DESCRIBED
DOCTOR PAN EVERYTHING FROM EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION IN
CLASSROOM SETTINGS WITH YOUTH
PEER EDUCATORS THROUGH THE
SCREENING THAT --
THE FORMER SPEAKER JUST
DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF SCREENING
AND CLINICAL AND CLASSROOM
SETTINGS FOR SUB DANGER
SUBSTANCE USE AND THROUGH EARLY
INTERVENTION BRIEF INTERVENTIONS
AND COUNSELING WAS STUDENTS.
SO WE THINK THIS IS A IDEAL
MODEL TO AM INTEGRATE INTO THE
PROGRAM AND LOOK FOR TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BRIAN LEE
WITH FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN KIDS
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF POLICE
CHIEF HERIFF'S DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND CRIME VICTIMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
REINFORCE WHAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM
MANY PEOPLE ABOUT HELP WITH SOAP
SO IMPORTANT PRIORITIZE
PREVENTION --
IN THIS --
AND THAT IS NOT ONLY THE IDEA
THAT YOU COULD THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY TO GET AHEAD OF THE PROBLEM
BUT ALSO GET MORE BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK.
BUT ALSO --
WE LOOK AT THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS IN ONE OF THE PRIMARY
STRATEGIES THAT WAS BEING SOLD
TO THE VOTERS WE TALK ABOUT THIS
WAS A CENTER LEYVA IS NOT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH HER ON THAT ISSUE --
IT WE KNOW THOSE NOT ONLY KEEP
KIDS OUT OF TROUBLE SUPERVISED
THE LESS LIKELY YOU TO ENGAGE IN
SUBSTANCE USE WILL ALSO DEVELOP
THOSE PROTECTIVE AND RESILIENCY
FACTORS THAT WE KNOW ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATRICK MORE TEAR WITH MISSION
READINESS IT'S A BI PARTISAN
NONPROFIT OF RETIRED ADMIRALS
AND GENERALS IN CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND  ALSO WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS THAT PER SHARE WITH
SOME OF THE PANELISTS TODAY.
ON PREVENTION --
YOU KNOW WE WE BELIEVE THAT WHEN
DECISION COMES DOWN TO FUNDING
BETWEEN PREVENTION AND TREATMENT.
THAT A BULK OF THAT MONEY SHOULD
GO TOWARD PREVENTION --
IT JUST MAKES COMMON SENSE THAT --
THAT IF WE SPEND MORE ON THE
FRONT AND WE'RE TO BE SAVING
MORE ON THE BACKEND.
AND PREVENTION IS.
TRULY THE BEST WAY TO SCHOOLS --
REMAIN SAFE HEALTHY AND ON THE
PATH TOWARD SUCCESS [inaudible]
THANKS.
WELCOME HERE IS.
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF SEIU
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE ANSWER AND ST JOHN'S
WELL CHILD.
AND FAMILY CENTERS IN LOS
ANGELES.
I'D LIKE TO SAY A COUPLE THINGS
THAT PEOPLE MAKE A STUPID
DIVIDING LINE BETWEEN PREVENTION
AND TREATMENT.
AND IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION.
AND DOES THAT BELONG TO AN
APARTMENT OR A GROUP OF PEOPLE
NO IT BELONGS TO THE KIDS RIGHT
SO THAT'S ONE THING.
THE OTHER THING IS WE CAN'T LOSE
IN THIS CONVERSATION.
THE IMPORTANT THING THAT HAPPENS
WITH FOSTER KIDS AND HOMELESS
KIDS WHO ARE THE MOST IN NEED AT
LEAST ON THE TREATMENT AND AND
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN TO SCHOOLS
AND DOESN'T HAPPEN THROUGH MOST
PART TREATMENT PROGRAMS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS FOR KIDS
[inaudible]
SO.
WHAT I THINK WE WOULD RECOMMEND
IS STOP [inaudible]
STEP BACK.
AND DO WHAT THE ONE THING THAT
EVERYONE IN THE WORKGROUP AGREED
TO WHAT USED TO US AN ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT'S OUT THERE WHAT WORKS
WHAT DOESN'T AND THEN BUILD THE
PLAN.
SOMEONE TELL WE DO THAT WE'RE
JUST FOR ONE LIKE SPIT BALLS AT
THE WALL.
RIGHT I MEAN I KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT THERE ARE STANDARDS IN
OTHER STATES THEIR STANDARDS IN
NEW JERSEY. FOR STUDENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND TO RUN A
PROGRAM LIKE THAT YOU NEED TO
CREDENTIAL RIGHT.
THE CHOSE YOU UNDERSTAND WE
SHOULD DO THAT YOU TREATMENT
ILLINOIS HAS USED TREATMENT
STANDARDS FOR PROGRAMS AND YOU
GET A CREDIT DID DID. TO DO IT.
SO WE NEED STANDARDS BITTER FOR
HIM.
FOR VERY IMPORTANT NO THANK YOU.
AND OF COURSE.
EVERYONE'S FREE TO ADD CONTINUE
TO SEND ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
DIRECTLY TO OUR TO OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF WELCOME.
YOU GET AFTERNOON ALEX TO CAPRI
ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA.
I PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
PROVIDES A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
FOCUS ON THE WHOLE CYCLE OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE EDUCATION
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
AND TREATMENT.
ARE TWENTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
ON THE GROUND TELLS US THAT
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION ARE CRITICAL TO
BREAKING THE CYCLE OF SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND YET IS OFTEN OR SEE
THE LEAST ATTENTION OR FUNDING.
TOO MANY FAMILIES GRAPPLE WITH
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA WHICH
IS OFTEN TIED WITH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND ABUSE AND AS PROFOUND
EFFECTS ON PARENTS AND ON OUR
YOUNGEST CHILDREN.
BREAKING THE CYCLE OF TRAUMA AND
FAMILIES IS A KEY ELEMENT OF
PREVENTION THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN SUBSTANCE MISUSE AND
POOR CHILD OUTCOMES IS CLEAR.
PIANO DRUG USE IS KNOWN TO CAUSE
NEGATIVE BIRTH OUTCOMES SUCH AS
LOW BIRTH WEIGHT FEEDING
DIFFICULTIES INCREASED
IRRITABILITY BY THE END PH#N
AND STANTON COGNITIVE AND
PHYSICAL DEVELOPMENT. FOR THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS FIRST RISE
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE SUPPORTED
FAMILY RESILIENCY PROGRAMS THAT
WORK WITH BOTH FAMILY AND
CHILD'S PREVENT POOR OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN.
THE GOALS OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR AROUND EDUCATION PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENT COMPLETELY ALIGNED
WITH EVIDENCE BASED TO
GENERATIONAL FAMILY RESILIENCY
PROGRAMS.
THAT STRENGTHEN FAMILIES SUCH AS
HOME VISITING PARENTING GROUPS
PARENT CHILD GROUPS AND HEALTH
RELATED SYSTEMS BUT FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TRADING
STRATEGIES ARE PRIORITIZED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF
PROPOSITIONS EXPIRE FUNDS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICTOR CHRISTY
WITH CALIFORNIA HELPLESS
ADVOCATES OF THE ADVOCACY
AFFILIATE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN NEARLY SEVEN
MILLION PATIENTS OF THE POP
SIXTY FOUR COALITION OF WHICH WE
ARE PART OF HAS AGREE ON A SET
OF PRINCIPLES --
THAT WE HOPE --
THE LEGISLATIVE --
AT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WILL CONSIDER
WHEN ALLOCATING POP SIXTY FOUR
REVENUE FUNDING AND SPECIFICALLY
I'D LIKE. TO ADD --
REALLY INTO THE 60% TREATMENT
FOR YOU --
AND WE WOULD --
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO HELP DETERMINE THE
PARTIES FOR THESE FUNDS.
IMPRIME PARAMETERS AND HOW THESE
BY SHOULD BE USED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FLOW JUNKO FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES.
I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT ALREADY MADE ABOUT
EQUITY AND THIS BEING A WAY TO
BE ABLE TO REPAIR SOME OF THE
DAMAGE DONE BY THE WAR ON DRUGS
AND THIS IS A RESTORATIVE --
FIND I'D ALSO LIKE TO ECHO THE
THE YOU PRIORITY A PREVENTION
BUT IN PARTICULAR I'D LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT WE THINK ABOUT PREVENTION
THEIR AGE RANGES HERE WERE
TREATMENT IS JUST NOT GOING TO
BE APPROPRIATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE DOING A WHOLE LOT OF
SUBSTANCE.
ABUSE TREATMENT FOR KIDS UNDER
TEN AND SO WE FOCUS ON SPENDING
THE MAJORITY OF THIS MONEY ON
TREATMENT SERVICES IT MEANS THAT
WE'RE MISSING OUT ON A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST BEFORE
HAND TO THE WE'RE TREATING FEWER
PEOPLE IN THE FUTURE.
FEDERAL LIKE FOR US TO CONSIDER
THAT AS ONE OF THE BILL OR
RUBRICS BY WHICH WE DECIDE HOW
WE'RE GOING --
TO TO ALLOCATE THE FUNDS IN
ADDITION I ALSO WANT TO THINK
ABOUT --
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN SAID EARLIER ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY AND CAPACITY AND
SO WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
HOW FUNDS CAN BE ALLOCATED AND
WHICH ORGANIZATIONS TO INVEST IN
REALLY THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE
GOING TO BE THE SUSTAINABLE --
INVESTMENT THAT OCCURRING
COMMUNITIES IT IS A ROBUST AND
WE'RE THINKING BROADLY ABOUT HOW
WE'RE DOING RESTORATIVE WORK AS
A RELEASE THE CHILDREN IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE NON FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA.
I ASK THAT AS EVERYONE MOVES
FORWARD ON THIS IMPORTANT --
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS THAT PEOPLE
A DOCTOR FRAMEWORK OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND PARTICULARLY
FOCUS ON UPSTREAM INVESTMENTS IN
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO HELP
YOU DEVELOP COPING SKILLS
EMOTIONAL MANAGEMENT SKILLS.
DECISION MAKING SKILLS AND ALSO
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENGAGE IN POSITIVE ACTIVITIES
WHICH ALL WILL HELP WITH PREVENT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE BUT ALSO TREAT
THEM AS WELL.
AS ASK THAT WE EVALUATE THE
SERVICES YES WE NEED TO ADDRESS
RISK FACTORS BUT I HOPE WE TAKE
MORE OF A STRENGTH BASED
APPROACH REPROACH AND FOCUS ON
BUILDING UPON.
ON THE PROTECTIVE FACTORS THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY HAVE.
ADDITIONALLY I HOPE THAT AS WE
ASSESS PROGRAMS I THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE SHOULD FIND THAT WE
MEANING FULLY INVOLVED THE
VOICES OF YOUTH THEY THEMSELVES
SHOULD BE SEEN AS ON AS EXPERTS
ON WHAT ARE AFFECTED PROGRAMS.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BECAUSE
CURRENTLY DCS DOES HAVE A YOUTH
ADVISORY GROUP WHICH HAS FIFTEEN
MEMBERS ZERO FROM WHERE YOUTH --
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
WHILE THERE IS THERE IS A FOCUS
ON PREVENTION I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE TREATMENT IS ALSO IMPORTANT --
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT AS WE
CONSIDER TRETMENT OPTIONS THAT
WE EXPAND THE DEFINITIONS OF
WHAT QUALIFIES TREATMENT AND
WHAT QUALIFIES AS QUALIFY
TREATMENT PROVIDERS AND I HOPE
THAT THOSE DEFINITIONS GO
OUTSIDE.
OF EXISTING CLINICAL LICENSING
AND CREDENTIALING STRUCTURES
BECAUSE OF MY EXPERIENCE WITH
YOU CAN EVEN ADDRESSES I'M
GROUPS YOUTH RESPOND MOST
EFFECTIVELY TO CULTURALLY
RELEVANT PROGRAMS THAT EXIST IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES WITH PEOPLE
CAN RELATE TO THEM.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS CONNOR BALDELLI
WHILE I'M WITH THE RISE YOUTH
CENTER IN RICHMOND WE ARE DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDER TO YOUNG PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND I SHARE SOME MATERIALS WITH
YOU AND TO SHARE ON THE TITLE OF
OP ED PIECE FROM ONE OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AS FOR YOUTH IN MY
CITY MARIJUANA IS A GO TO
TREATMENT FOR TRAUMA.
I THINK IT'SREALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND --
WHEN WE'VE TALKED TO HUNDREDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE IN RICHMOND WEST
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY NUMBER ONE
COPING MECHANISM FOR TRAUMA
DISTRESS IS SMOKING MARIJUANA
NOT BECAUSE IT'S RECREATIONAL
THEY'RE COPING WITH TH
ATMOSPHERE TRAUMA THEY ARE IN?
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION
EDUCATION FOR ADULTS WHO ARE
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO ENGAGE IN
LOBBYING HEALING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE --
I'M ALSO PART OF AND IT'S A LONGNAME IN THERE --
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT HAS
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU HAVE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY FOR WHAT I'M
ASKING YOUR TODAY'S ACTUALLY TO
CREATE TIME --
TO MEET WITH YOU ALL IN YOUR
THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE IT'S A
HEALTH ISSUE IT'S A RACIAL
JUSTICE THAT YOU IT'S ABOUT
TRUTH AND RECONCILIATION IT'S
ABOUT REPARATIONS.
I ALSO ASK THAT WE REALLY STAY
AWAY FROM EVIDENCE THESE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY PATHOLOGY
EYES AND STIGMATIZE YOUNG PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND OUTCOMES ACTUALLY
HAVE TO BE DRIVEN BY YOUNG
PEOPLE AND OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
CANNOT BE ACTUALLY DECIDED BY
THE STATE --
AS A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION WE ARE --
VERY BURDENED BY THE OUTCOMES IN
THE COMPLIANCE MECHANISMS OF
STATES --
AND AND THE STATE --
AGENCIES AND THEY DON'T MATCH UP
TO WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE NEED WHAT
YOUNG PEOPLE WANT AN OFTEN
THEY'RE VERY DEHUMANIZING SO WE
HOPE TO SEE WHAT THE CONVENING
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON THAT TIME
MALACHI ALL MEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN PARTNERSHIP AND
WHAT I WOULD URGE THE ODD
CHAIRED AND AND MEMBERS TO DO IS.
TO CONSIDER THE NARRATIVE AROUND
HOW -- OF
MOTHER OR FATHER WENT TO JAIL
GOT OUT COULDN'T GET A JOB
COLLEGE TUITION --
HOUSING CHILDREN TRAUMATIZED
SEPARATED FROM FAMILIES THEY
COULDN'T BUY A HOME OR STARTER
STRONG BUSINESS ULTIMATELY THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD GETS GENTRIFIED.
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT
WITH THE YOU FUND IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TREAT THE THE THE
THE THE AFTERMATH OF WHAT HAS
CONTINUE TO IMPACT THE WHOLE
CHILD.
AND SO OUT WOULD ECHO THOSE --
COMMENTS MADE BEFORE AROUND THE
NEED TO SPEND AT LEAST TWO
THIRDS OF THESE DOLLARS ON
PREVENTION --
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE A TRAGEDY IF
FURTHER INVESTMENT AND TREATMENT
CENTERS AS OPPOSED TO INNOVATIVE
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES THAT BECOME
PLACES WHERE --
IMPACTED CHILDREN --
AND YOUNG ADULTS CAN BE HEALED
THEY CAN GET EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT
THEY CAN WORK THEY CAN ALSO GET
HOUSING AND SO SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES BECOMES A RITICAL.
PART OF THE INNOVATION --
AND THE EXPENDITURE OF THESE
DOLLARS THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LUIS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEARS ADAM AB
AGENCY I'VE STATEWIDE A RUNAWAY
AND HOMELESS YOUTH PROVIDERS FOR
THE STATE AND REMIND YOU TO NOT
FORGET OUR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
AS WE THINK ABOUT IT THEY ARE
OFTEN A FORGOTTEN POPULATION AND
ALL THE CONVERSATIONS AND ONE OF
THE BIGGEST INDICATORS ACCORDING
TO ACHIEVE AND HOW STUDY AT
AROUND WHY YOU THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IS
THEIR LACK OF A GED.
AND A FOUR POINT TIME FIVE TIMES
GREATER THAN OTHER PEERS IN
THEIR POPULATION AND PROGRAMS IN
SUPPORT AND SERVICES FOR PROGRAM
SERVING YOUTH --
THAT OUR HOME LAST ARE
EXCEEDINGLY UNDER FUNDED IN THE
STATE AND HAVE CONTINUOUSLY BEEN
SO WE MADE DAPPLED OF ONE TIME
DOLLARS BUT I'M GOING FUNDING.
IS VERY LIMITED AND IF WE REALLY
WANT TO GET THESE YOU THE FUTURE
WE REALLY NEED TO BE BLE TO BUT
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
THEM.
AND THEIR COMMUNITY IS THAT
EMPLOY A TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACH POSITIVE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT HAVE YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARDS AND THIS LEGISLATURE TOOK
A HISTORIC MOMENT LAST YEAR.
HAVEN'T PASSING SB NINE ONE
EIGHT AM TO REALLY HAVE A HOME
AT STATE GOVERNMENT FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
ONE ENCOURAGE OTHER HOME
ACCORDING TO FINANCING COUNCIL
BE BROUGHT INTO ANY DISCUSSIONS
AROUND.
HOW TO PROP SIXTY FOUR FUNDS CAN
BEUTILIZED IN THIS IS SO THAT
YOU CAN REALLY BE PART THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
WELCOME I'D.
BEEN ENEMIES NOT TO KNOW WHAT
CHILDREN NOW AND CHILDREN NOW TO
THE WHOLE CHILD APPROACH --
COVERING THE FULL RANGE OF KEY
CHILDREN'S ISSUES FROM PRENATAL
TO AGE TWENTY SIX AND WE WERE
TALKING EARLIER ABOUT BREAKING
DOWN SILOS AND WORKING ACROSS TO
REALLY.
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF ENSURING
REAL YOUTH EDUCATION PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND
EDUCATION --
AND I'D ECHO THE FIRST FIVE
COMMENTS AROUND ENSURING THAT
PREGNANT BREASTFEEDING MOMS --
ARE GETTING EARLY EDUCATION AS
WELL.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M WHOLLY MICHON I REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES AND I'M HERE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF OUR PRESIDENT ELSE
AN ALOE WHO IS ALSO THE C. E. O.
OF TARZANA TREATMENT CENTERS --
I WOULD START OUT TO SAY THAT
THE THE THE ASSOCIATION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AREN'T
WHEN INITIATIVE WAS PASSED OUT
CONVENED.
THE GROUP WHICH ULTIMATELY
BECAME THE PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT HAS
BEEN MENTIONED A THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING.
OF THE PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
A CONVENE AS I SAID CONVENE AN
MATT FROM TWO THOUSAND YOU END
OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THROUGH --
THE A A THROUGH AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHEN THEY
ADOPTED THE CONSENSUS DOCUMENT
THAT HAS BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO.
ARE IN ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
SPOKEN HERE TODAY BOTH AS PART
OF THE PANEL AND IS PART OF
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPATED IN.
OF THE ON GOING DISCUSSIONS OVER
THE TWO YEARS ALMOST TWO YEARS
OF THE CONSENSUS DOCUMENT THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
CONTINUES TO ME.
AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT THEY ARE
MATT.
EVERYBODY CAME A CAME UP BECAUSE
OF THEIR INTEREST.
AND THEIR COMMITMENT TO CHILDREN.
AND TO SEEING TO IT THAT THERE
ARE SERVICES AVAILABLE.
AND THEY CAME OUT WITHOUT.
ANY AND WE CONVENE THIS AND WE
HAD WE BEEN CONTINUING THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
WITHOUT ANY OUTSIDE.
SUPPORT IT IS ONLY THROUGH OUR
COMMITMENT THAT WE DO THIS I
QUICKLY HAVE --
FOR THINGS TO SUMMARIZE FOR YOU
THAT ARE IN THE A CONSENSUS
DOCUMENT THAT ARE --
IMPORTANT. ONE IS THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO IS FOR A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
AND I HAVE THE OTHER TWO WHICH I
WILL --
SUBMIT TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND THEN JUST LET YOU KNOW THAT
BOTH THE PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE AND CAD P.
AS THE ORGANIZATION CONVENIENT
CONVENER.
OF OUR OF HERE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND UP.
UP PROVIDE ANY WORK THAT WE CAN
ANY SUPPORT THAT WE CAN FOR THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND PLEASE SAYS SMITH --
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF.
CASEY NO OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I
JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE IS
THAT BOTH THEIR DIRECTORS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE FAR
HEALTHCARE SERVICES OF STATE FOR
THE ENTIRE HEARING THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE TO
LISTEN TO EVERYONE PRESENT.
AND LA --
FOLKS ARE ALSO HERE AS WELL AS
WHAT THEY CALL THE PRESENTERS
AND FOR BEING HERE AND ALL THE
PEOPLE MADE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO WITH THAT IN AUGUST OKAY WELL
THAT THIS IS A HEARING IS OF THE
COMMITTEES ON HEALTH AND
COMMUNICATION IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU